[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it was a dramatic penultimate round and
the candidates in Berlin as the leaders
could feel a mountain of pressure with a
finish line in sight shock rearmament
ear off kept his chances alive by
knocking Alexander Grisham out of the
running while American superstar Fabiano
Khurana won a wild game against Levon
Aronian to once again stake a claim atop
the standings
Wilma Madeira of car yaki and ding are
Caruana grabbed their place in history
and challenged Magnus Carlsen for the
world championship crown the answer in a
door die last round for all the marbles
coming up next
[Music]
welcome to today in chess I'm Jennifer
Sajadi and here with Yasir Sarah won and
we have an incredible show for you it is
the final round of the candidates and
Seaton Lewis's own Fabiano Cara Juana is
a leading Yasir with a halfway point to
go this is the championship round and I
am I think this is going to be the most
exciting day in chess since the 1972
Bobby Fischer match we have in
incredible games that we are following
let's take a look at the standings and
the pairings for today well there it is
half point ahead of the field Viviano
marijuana with his game currently
pending against Grisha Sergei Carr yakun
and mama Diarra
also in the hunt with seven and a half
slim chances but real for a dinger end
of China those are the four players who
could potentially win but let's see what
the pairings look like as those three
critical games are still going on there
was unexpected I mean as expected there
was a short draw between LaVon and
Wesley both eliminated from the
competition
absolutely and stop it and it's starting
at the top there we have Fabiana nursing
that aqua ponic lead he can't get
himself into a tie his tie breaks are
really poor so he he a win clinches very
important game going on there Sergey
karyakin Tingler in we're looking at
this position we're thinking dangler and
my twin Vladimir Kramnik versus Shak
that's a Donnybrook well shacks up upon
that Vladimir has a very promising
looking attack Jennifer it's hit we're
on pins and needles here in the studio
indeed
anything could happen but one thing's
for sure it looks even better for
Fabiano right now than it did a couple
hours ago when the game started right
but we also have Grandmaster Maurice
Ashley for the potential road to victory
for any of the four players were still
in it and that number four think about
it there are only eight players in the
competition and half the field could win
the title today that's just simply
incredible
it shows how competitive the tournament
has been so far and what more could you
expect from what is offensively
one of the best candidates we've seen in
decades
well first of all let's take a look at
the players ding Lauren he didn't seem
like he had a chance and I misspoke
yesterday saying he was knocked out but
it turns out due to the tiebreaks
there's a slam road to victory if he
wins today against carjacking and
managerial draws that's important
he needs my materials to draw and tie
with him and also at Caruana losses in
that three-way tie
then he we go to the head-to-head tie
break and he wins out having defeated
the Madeira
if a Madeira does not score any points
then ding will lose the Caruana
on a tie break just to show you how
close things are well that's his only
route to victory
meantime car yakun with a win would be
fantastic for him or a draw well if he
draws and Madeira loses he would need
members you have to lose and Caruana to
lose in order for him to get the crown a
winner however gives them better tie
breaks against Fabi it probably only
draws and that's super important and
also he needs my Madeira of not to win
as well because my major nerves
tiebreaks are better than his following
all this folks well let's go even deeper
my Madeira makes it simple
he beats chronic and Khurana draws
that's it
he doesn't care what car yakin does he
doesn't care what ding does drop a bomb
all you want he wins it all that's what
he wants just a defeat chronic but he's
got his hands full right now we'll see
whether or not he can pull that off
and finally karo on the man of the hour
he's leading the tournament a win by him
and he doesn't even have to discuss
tiebreaks he's in clear by himself but
there's a precarious situation if he
draws bridge truth he will be begging
for car yeah kinoma Madeira of not to
win he will lead them to you the draw or
lose because either one of them wins and
ties him that's it he's out on tie
breaks because he has the worst high
brakes of all you followed all that well
we will not have to follow the games to
see how that unfolds as it's gotten very
hot in Berlin we will see and keep it up
right now as today in chess continues
Wow thank you for that Maurice and what
games we have going on we've just seen
this movie
he three to g4 by Sergei karyakin in his
matchup with ding and I'm looking at the
move Queen East six Jennifer I just the
I had this idea that this pawn on g4 has
no defenders so even though everything's
tied to the f3 score at the moment
there's this move Queen b6 hold on my
mouse is not cooperating with me but I
got it Queen e6 now I'm hanging the rook
if you take with the rook geez okay I'm
having a bad day today to start the show
yes exactly Queen takes g4 check winning
back the rook unless you play King f2
but then I have this massive check
separating the Kings protection from the
rook the king act would have to drop
back and rook takes and that's all she
wrote didn't make it in to take my rocks
yes exactly
so Queen e6 may force the Queen
sacrifice Queen takes rook takes rook
takes Queen takes g4 check again
attacking the rook on f3 the king could
not go up because of that same Queen g2
check separating the king and the rook
the rook would have to step across its a
g3 and then I was looking at the Queen
invading with Queen e2 my first
impressions are is this has to be very
good for for black that there is an open
F file and after rook f1 there there is
counter play for all but maybe I have G
form well this is this is the type of
games that are ongoing on all the boards
really really really sharp stuff
first impressions though are that ding
is really really doing very well at this
moment right that that move h3 really
turned the tables exactly
earlier after the move King g2h 495
turned out to meet a mistake because
this is this really star move h3 check
I'm sure in his calculations Sergei had
considered this thought King takes h3
I'm attacking the rook if the rook
crashes down I'll trade everything I'll
be better but what he admits is this
super shot g5g for check double
exclamation mark if you take with a king
you're like a you're likely simply just
to get mated and you can't take with the
pawn because the rook on f1 is hanging
here that would cost a rook and if you
drop back with your king after g4 well
then I take the pawn with check for king
king and queen so that move h3 check was
a really star move was missed by Sergei
or perhaps he missed g4 but either way
it's kind of interesting because he's
got this positional edge with a knight
on d5 being such a strong piece but when
you've got that positional advantage
sometimes you forget about the tactics
and this is one of those case Jennifer
he forgot about the tactics and after
rook takes f3 it was Dean who has the
advantage but now let's go to our
crucial matchups between Vladimir and
and Shaq Shaq's upon up Maryse yes and
curiously because I spoke about with
Europe's is concerned a draw is like a
loss if Fabi draws he he needs to catch
up so you would think he's in a must-win
situation but he did something that was
incredibly curious and he actually did
it a couple of times in this game in
this position a pawn sacrifice has
already been essayed by Crom Aquino
Kramnik is a fighter it doesn't matter
that he's knocked out of the competition
he wants to play chess is going to play
every single game but in this position
down a pawn is Cromley and queen c5 was
played offering Queen exchange of course
cranly could have none of it he played
Queen d2 and then Queen before offering
a queen exchange queen back to c2 and
now Queen c5 now that's a repetition of
the position you think why is he doing
that if he draws the game then of course
he's in trouble
if mommy if Fabiano draws or if Kuryakin
wins you'd have to bet on a loss by
Fabiano in order to stay alive and he is
up upon so offering to repeat okay maybe
he wouldn't have done so but chronic was
the first to say now I don't want to see
that position Queen D 694 and now Queen
back to c5 which means Cromley could
have played a night back to e5 and
repeated yet again what was mama D our
strategy we'll never know because maybe
he knows chronic is not one to want to
repeat moves and they say crumbling down
played the independent Queen f3 which
sacrifices a piece with the idea of
sacrificing a rook in this position and
now if you were to take here bishop
takes and suddenly its mate coming as
the Queen's under attack and f7 is
hanging as well so after Queen f3 he
played a very solid c6 by the way in
this position Queen f3 Queen takes rook
takes you could also try this move f5
and test him in this position trying to
win a whole piece but I have to look
back to d1 apparently pawn takes losses
to the very spectacular look down that's
i popping move rook to d8 Bishop takes
Queen f8 is mate and if you play Queen
takes then Queen c3 and suddenly there's
problems g7 is hanging c7 is hanging is
not easy to defend this position you
play this move then even Queen check is
hanging as well with a queen penetrating
into the f7 square and that is all she
wrote so very enterprising chassis
played c6 instead diamond 0 of saying no
I'm not gonna let you knock me out and
they made a couple more moves from this
position wild games and all the American
fans are holding on by their fingernails
as these games are not just solid
they're crazy and rooting for Fabiano
Caruana
what is he going to do in his position
seems to have improved somewhat but we
wanted him to win the game he's that
gonna happen not that clear
well thank you Maurice and that game of
Fabiana by the way again really looks
like a good position to my mind I'm a
noble French defense player loved those
French setups and it seems to me
this was actually a very critical
position right back here
Sascha took the long-term decision he
really did not like this pin his very
awkward
pin against his knight on f3 he decided
to dissolve that pin with the move
Knight the d4 may look spectacular but
it's actually a very simple idea if
fabbi had captured and grabbed a pond
there is this nasty move Bishop f5
trapping the Queen and after g6 Bishop
takes pawn takes Bishop takes d5 Grichuk
would be the one with an advantage so
Fabiana said okay you want to trade
Queens let's go take stakes
take stakes and we have this middle game
two bishops versus Bishop Knight but I
really like this decision by fabbi c5 c4
and the idea is once the bishop drops
back he wants to play b5 and so he can
play moves like a 5 and d4 in the near
future and target this pawn on b4 the
problem from whites point of view is
this Bishop on g3 really is a passive
piece Griffith will will look for an
opportunity to bring that guy back into
the game but it seems to me at this
exact moment that that B's building up
at an initiative and I like it this
would be a way to do it
oh yeah so we won't have to look about
tiebreaks
and all of that stuff but there was a
very nice quote from fabbi about the
loss that he had earlier yes that's
right coach Q chess waiting for us chess
said that Bobby looked very cool after
the big win and actually said that
losing the game against Sergey Kuryakin
and room 12 helped his outlook he was
too nervous trying to hold on to my lead
and it ruined my play for a few games so
I felt much better before the game in
which he undefeated Aronian quite
spectacularly now that's ironic you
the game your chances of winning the
tournament seemingly plummet but that's
what puts you back into the driver's
seat in and wins you again and now you
could say the same thing today about
Mammadov in-car yakin that he might have
felt less anxiety knowing that Bobby was
the clear favorite but so far I think I
like Bobby's position the best of the
three of them absolutely well there's a
great book out I'd recommend to you guys
to get it go how to perform under
pressure and the authors in that book
talk about pressure and of course we are
always in the pressure cooker when we
play chess events and the point is that
often when you are under pressure you go
conservative you start to do traditional
solutions you play it safe and that's
what Bobby did in this tournament he got
a slight lead and you didn't see the
normal Fabi doesn't mean he has to play
better than himself he just had to be
his normal self but he lost some of that
edge because he is now under the
pressure of trying to maintain that lead
you see it a lot of times at sports
teams are up enough points they think
let's just play it safe and that's
exactly the edge the opponent needs to
come back and hungrily claw back in the
game and then were you trying to catch
it again you just don't do it because
you already started playing safe and you
lose your momentum Bobby made it very
clear he got knocked on his rear end and
he said whoa I no longer have any lead
to nurse it's time to go back to
fighting and clawing my way into this
competition and that's exactly what he
did
winning his last game playing
freewheeling chess and now this position
which looks quite promising for him as
well is it nice to lose no but it's a
sign of a champion that when you lose
you bounce back and Bobby has shown it
so far
absolutely what an exciting round this
is again just from the top of the show I
just feel like this may be the biggest
day in chess for American chess fans
since 1972 this is just amazing stuff
biggest day of the year will take place
in London in November I had dates for
that yeah that's right I saw that they
were in November 8th to the 28th we see
right here ok
okay we're the London it leader this
year if Fabiano wins today will be that
absolutely and of course there are many
permutations were a draw will also get
him bat see that's right but a win hey
that's that's the way way to show Magnus
I see Magnus Carlsen himself tweeted
today well before the round started he
said that there was a 70% chance at
Carolina would win which was way haider
right but I guess he just believed in
foggy looking at the games and also
looking at the pairing so it was really
interesting to hear Magnus his thoughts
these players very very well so he's
he's putting in the the experience
factor throwing the elbow does you know
what I played against this guy this guy
this guy in this situation I think it's
about right but 70% is very very high
huge glad to hear it we'll just grab
that Thank You Magnus but my feeling is
I'm still sitting here trying to hold it
together exactly speaking of trying to
hold it together I think that's this
case of Sasha Gray shook because he's
looking at a very clear pond storm
coming on the queenside let's just let's
just take a move I'm not saying this is
a very good move or a very bad move f2
a3 the idea simply to bring this way
we're a bishop on g3 it's really not
doing a lot back to f2 and back into the
game looking at a line that goes like a
five no what are we going to do about a
five are we gonna go Bishop f2 well
we're not going to be very happy that
after takes takes this rook on a eight
is going to invade White's camp rook a3
going after the base this home chain on
c3 and one of the nice tactics now I
know there's Bishop g5 and others but
just one nice tactic that you have to be
aware of is that after b4 this pawn is
going to fall and in the resulting
position to connected past bonds are
going to be all she wrote so
one of those French positions where
somehow you miss played against the
veteran and yeah you're defensive in the
end game you have to defend real well
not to get like steamrolled by the the
Queen side pressure exactly I remember a
lot of games of mine were after moved
like a four I have played a five okay
please take my pawn so I can play d4 at
the end then it's rolling rolling
rolling you mentioned not in another
show the Mongolian Mongolian Mongolian
tactic so then we have a position Knight
takes on b5 now here we pause for a
second because one very intriguing idea
is to sacrifice a piece which i think is
unnecessary but just to put it on the
board to show you what i come on yes
pawn takes pawn takes now for the piece
good grief I need a I need something
underneath my good it yes bad it moving
properly that's right my mouse my mouse
abilities are really bad three connected
passed pawns in the center and that
looks really really dangerous but
there's another move how about this one
Jen Knight to e7 very simple idea just
recapture the pawn with the night and if
be fixed and it c6 Knight to b5 and
going anywhere on its own it's all about
this crucial pawn here upon e5 2 how
garbage is that if we could just swipe
that off the board yes we would have
some opportunity if you could play b7
your favorite a c6 so it's actually
really killing a lot of our piece
activity that exactly yes yes that pawn
on e5 is really getting in the way
no no that Bishop on g3 so I'm just
saying at this moment this is actually a
crucial moment here for Sasha because he
can see that a 5 is going to tear down
his Queen side and he's he may be forced
to go into a tactical variation that
actually it's very promising for Fabiano
and again as we've been saying I started
the show fabbi wins this game we don't
have to consider earn ourselves with any
tiebreaks anymore it's just over the
abbey we'll win the tournament
it's funny how obsessive people are
getting about the math of these
tiebreaks it's almost like the anxiety
of the situation is so high that you
cling to numbers and math that's right
because I see it like everybody tweeting
about it writing about it there's so
many simulations and opinions it's it's
kind of interesting yeah
and here are the official rules of the
playoffs we've got a first of all head
to head and then secondly most wins
third a more complex system called son
and born burger which boils down to how
well did the players that you beat do
yes so if you beat people who did better
in the tournament you got a little bit
better in the tiebreak now finally we
see the two-game rapid match as a
playoff and that would be the fourth tie
break which is not going to happen you
know my brother mathematically
eliminated indeed my brother Greg Sahadi
actually just wrote a blog where he
talked about how normally even loves
team playoffs but there is a way in
which this this format these tie breaks
which I just generally don't like they
are actually adding a lot of drama to
the final round so you know just in this
particular case because it means that
everybody is in a must-win situation and
normally Fabi could really close to a
draw and really try to draw because he
would be guaranteed at least a playoff
now he's got to watch his back exactly
so it is it actually is interesting and
and he pointed out you know that some
tournaments do the Blitz or the rapid at
the beginning yes so you kind of
determine your tie Rick's before the
event which I also think is a really
fascinating idea Norway tested that once
I think Wow well I mean I'm still on
pins and needles what's going on Maurice
well Greg always has some really
interesting ideas and I did read that
this morning as well I think that yes
you can have situations where because
the tie breaks are what they are you get
drama like you have now but it just
feels unfair to the players you've
played all these games and you get to a
point and for example the situation
where Diggler in way
nothing against ting he's played
wonderful chess this tournament
wonderful great fighting chess but
imagine he wins by maduro of drawers and
Fabi loses so now they're all tied and
the way to break that tie all three with
eight points is to do the head-to-head
inside that group
well ding Lauren is the only one who has
a victory in that group against the
group he will have defeated my metier of
and so he would get through in that
situation but think about it Fabi would
look at you and say wait a minute this
guy won two games in the whole
competition
I won four he didn't beat me we've drew
both our games i won four games I played
an amazing fighting chest and because he
beat some other due to game I'm not out
with my score tied why don't you go to
the next tiebreak since he's better than
my Madeira let's say mummy Jerome is out
now let's do us head-to-head and it's
ahead we draw and I end up on the next
tie break with more wings therefore I
win the rules actually don't preclude
that interpretation Robbie might say to
the to the toffee day
why can't we interpret it this way I
don't think there's anything clear that
says you can't do that and because of
those kind of convoluted complications
and conversations I think the tiebreak
is just flawed head-to-head is the only
one I respect quite honestly I say
head-to-head I beat you you definitely
don't have a chance but the rest of them
just seems like a crapshoot and it's
just best that you have a playoff yeah
it's head to head not head to head to
head we've got the playoffs sorry do
what's at stake here is the million
dollar prize in a way yes because
winning the candidates might only pay
just over 100k but on top of that that
ticket to London in November that's
gonna be worth a minimum of 500k if you
win the world champ over 700 K but it's
the lifetime achievement yes or for
being the Challenger that is huge the
sponsorship the endorsements the PR the
training that will you know give you an
experience for life to make you more
likely to win again they call that the
Matthew effect
it's laviano trains for this world
championship even if you move
is he'll be a better player for the rest
of his life and you're more likely to
qualify and win again right and also the
experience factor and everything else no
it's a career changing moment for four
players and we're just wondering who's
going to be the Challenger we know it's
one of four players at the moment it
looks very good for Fabiano but it ain't
over till it's over
no certainly not knowing that the other
players have a lot at stake and I'm
really thrilled though with Fabiano's
position in the fact that even if
kramnik has a meltdown does blunders and
time pressure the nice thing is father
you can see that happen in and then
still have a chance to press in his game
so right now he's really going for that
to results and I you know you can't ask
for more right and again I don't ask me
why but we did see by the way in this
position a four and fabbi
did not go for those lines with a five
that I had mentioned instead he just
defended upon on a six which is fine now
fabbi has ideas like capturing on a four
rerouting the knight b5 so that the
bishop will be forced to capture so f2
f3 and now I find myself really
attracted to a peace sacrifice don't ask
me why but Knight takes pawn takes
Bishop takes the idea is if I can get
you to move your rook then I want to
just post up with Bishop to c3 and I'm
eyeballing 3-connected passed pawns
coming cascading down the board with B 4
B 3 and so forth and so on it looks very
very attractive really tough for a human
to play against that but of course
Grisha God is more a little bit more
than human being a super Grandmaster but
I do notice that at the more amateur or
semi-professional level playing against
those pawns it's just super difficult
does that change tremendously at this
level no there was a wonderful press
conference interview with Fabiano where
he mentioned that after
that he made a draw he said while he was
so happy not to be playing against four
connected pass pawns and three connected
pass bonds I mean he's specifically
cited that no it's really really really
tough you have to work harder than your
opponent your opponent's moves are
obvious right calculate it over and over
it's just kind of like being attacked
but instead of being attacked in the
traditional sense you're the threat is
not your king but yeah yeah you just did
all these guys coming at you but back
over to you
Maurice because I'm sure there's
breaking events going on and the other
games no kidding
thank goodness it's crazy what's going
on in this position with my Madeira and
Kramnik remember mama dear our winds and
Fabi does not win his game that Mommy is
in regardless of what anyone else in the
competition does and cronic has got all
of us up by Johnny fans thinking please
just keep playing tension-filled chess
and sacrifice if you will and give our
boy a chance and that's what's happening
right now remember he was already down
upon was crime thinking in this position
you played Bishop to d3 and after 9 f6
now solidly protecting his King the move
easy for trying to insist in this
position so that he can get it maybe an
e5 push well II five came in first and
chronic dropped back to e3 attacking the
Queen and after Queen to b4 now the pawn
on b2 is under pressure and cronic said
I don't care take it if you want to and
now he's gotten the pawn back now we
have even material but only for one move
because my Maduro said no I'm gonna keep
the extra pawn you prove this
compensation still this Bishop though is
ready to jump into the game at a
moment's notice after Knight takes on e5
and this Knight is under attack Bishop
to f4 and by the way in this position it
was a absolutely crazy move that mami
drive could have tried to move g5 we're
a disruptive chess
this move would have been very tricky to
meet as a matter of fact the Knights
hanging so you can't just take because
of Queen takes and you with your knight
hanging and pawn takes on top the move
Knight to c4 saving your knight seem
force but then this Intermezzo Bishop -
geez
we're hitting the Queen and the rook and
you can't move your queen because of
takes and you get into this position
where you have to trade off here and
then take and take and take and after
Bishop c5 Black is the one who's saying
I got some initiative here and your
pawns are fractional on this side I got
a three to one on the other side g5
would have been super interesting but he
didn't play it it was a bit risky and
instead after Bishop f4 he played the
solid Bishop to e6 and this one begs the
question what about rook to B once
looks like another sac and rook b7 is
black super solid now looking very
strong on this side black has to pass
pawns count them but White has some
smidgen of activity this game is wild
and oh by the way it's a move 29 taking
on rook takes b7 locke is encroaching
like crazy guys mmm this is a round of
trash this is this is not something that
Fabiano fans will want to see a victory
by Madeira of means that Bobbie must
must win his game well when you mention
that there's 11 moves to make and we're
at 11:30 you think about the fact that
in the the Grisha game there's even more
game moves to make so ritika yeah I
think they're only a move 22 or
something in that right yeah what are
you two eating moves to make total time
controller already at 11:30 so that's uh
that's gonna keep our and also how much
is Fabiana paying attention to the other
boards I mean he's got to a little bit
usually it's not recommended you gotta
Zone in and focus but the stakes are too
high here you got to pay a little
attention right now by the way Fabiano
took a very very nice positional
approach he didn't go for any of those
sacrificial lines as promising as they
may appear instead he's saying look
White's two bishops are very meaningful
I'll put first of all the move Bishop g5
it's a dual-purpose move it freezes this
rook on d1 the rook on d1 has to
maintain its guard over the D 2 square
you cannot allow this Dart
a bishop to land on the D 2 square which
would attack the base of the pond chain
on c3 secondly he's saying look in the
near future I may also play Bishop f4
forcing either a trade of bishops or the
loss of this pawn on e5 you take away
White's two bishops then he has no play
in the position so this is a very safe
solid approach by black this move Bishop
g5 I like his position but now let's
just move to the game of dangler in
because we've got two pawns but before I
do that we have a phone call generous
welcome to the show
hi my name is Patricia McCarney from
Virginia and I have a question who you
think could be the biggest challenger to
be joining magnets on the lodge invasion
question we actually have a how all the
players have stacked up against Magnus
bottom line Magnus has an edge against
everybody in classical chest
except for Dengler and they've only had
two games and both of those games were
raw but we had some pretty pretty
decisive results with Magnus Carlsen
named the champions showdown against
England yes yes
here's the actual only in classical
chess
these are only their classical games but
if you look at that table you see that
Fabiano and Mecca kramnik Kramnik has a
great result - I mean I know it might
sound biased but I picked Fabiano
kuranes having the best chances and then
I would also like to see Vladimir
Kramnik okay because of the preparation
I mean I think that the preparation that
Bobby people put in and execute will be
really good yeah I was just saying of
the four potential challengers Dengler
in again not enough games but I think
Bobby would actually be the player you
would have a pre-tournament no
pre-tournament I was actually glad
America
and the two Americans of course but I'm
just saying of these four players
Fabiano has really defeated Magnus the
most times and it's important that's an
important stat right the fact is fear
counts respect counts you can see some
players when they said against Magnus
they think how am I gonna beat this guy
I mean he's an incredible player he's
been an incredible champion and he's
gotten as AI has 2889 on the live
ratings you think you're playing against
a god but someone has to say bring it
back down earth sorry he's not perfect
he can be beat and the person in that
list we're talking about is Fabiana car
running said but I didn't just beat him
once I beat him not just twice I've been
him not just three times not just for I
beat him five times
I'm looking to now get the rings on the
other hand I can beat this guy as the
fact is he's beaten me nine times yes
but we're training blows to a point and
if I just get a a bit better maybe and
show better nerves maybe I can catch him
and Koryak can show that it's possible
to fight Magnus Magnus really seems
uninvent scible sometimes but Kramnik
sorry car yakin showed in a match that
is possible to at least fight Magnus
Carlsen and I think that car that that
Caruana will come in with that
self-belief that he's got a shot against
this great champion absolutely and big
big development going on here in
fabiana's game because am I looking at
sacrifices I keep looking at sacrifices
for Fabiano as if he's desperate or
something but again a lot of these
sacrifices really I find attractive yeah
but they look really good so we we just
saw this move Bishop g5 the bishop did
drop back to f2 Fabiano posting up with
his bishop on f4 give me this pawn on e5
but if the bishop the bishop can take
this pawn on e5 followed by Bishop takes
c3 Knight takes b4 it's an avalanche
these black pawns will just race up the
board on the Queen
site and easily win the game Bishop to
c5 looking for the possibility of Bishop
to d6 to defend the pawn on e5 from the
side has improved a big time however it
takes pawn I love it and after Bishop
takes f8 and rook takes FA and I'm just
sitting there saying boy how are you
going to defend this pawn on c3 this
just looks really really attractive to
me and yeah I guess that the move has to
be played as rookie 3 yeah you've got to
defend this pawn on b4 on c3 which
depends upon on before now I realize
unfortunately that my intended move had
been D 5 D 5 D 4 but I see that there is
rook takes sacrificing the exchange back
and white is doing fine in this line and
I was there any way for you to interpret
late Bishop takes c3 now because I work
takes c6 right right and I I am the
other hand yeah can't work T 6 is too
strong exactly I'm laying my work into
the game the night and hey come on is
intake let's just continue that line one
further move because there is this crazy
move Knight d4 attacking the rook
attacking the bishop yeah yeah yeah you
have to calculate and you have to have
nerves of steel and so you're saying
like I could place I can't play with
fixed e-fortress Bishop takes d4 comes
with a nice check correct interesting my
Wow lots of it's very tempting
possibilities very tempting by the way
we could also maybe just King takes I
was thinking maybe I can play for in
that type of line well then we get the
variation that you wanted which was
Bishop takes c3 and 90s D so if you if I
could just get this one thing in I want
to bring my king very nicely to d6
- easy for my hands come loose over to
you what what's caught your eye man I
was looking at something else and you
played that and I want to look at that
[Laughter]
today other than the draw between two
players who were knocked out of the
competition these are the three games
are all we could have hoped for
every single game full of fight full of
desire by these players even the ones
who have nothing to play for are playing
like that that it's so critical what
they do
first of all Grizz shook we joked
yesterday what would be Grisham's
motivation and we talked about maybe
some money might come in from a phone
call from Moscow clearly Christian
doesn't need that he's a fighter he's a
gladiator and he says I'm coming to the
board what do I have to lose anyway
let's play some chess let's see what
you've got prove yourself to be a real
champion so Brister playing now
christian korilla grandmaster guerrilla
our colleague made a point that Grichuk
also knows that if the ball starts
bouncing the right way for Fabiano then
that is if either mummy-ji Arab or both
my material man and in karaoke and draw
their games then Grisha could always say
you know what let's just take a draw and
stop the struggle there's no reason to
continue because I would have to defeat
you if he's in trouble then he's if he's
in trouble he's not in any trouble you
might say keep hitting you so he's
showing gladiator spirit as is kramnik
and look at this position Bishop to e6
Crowley has no chance to win this this
tournament but rook takes on b7 Bishop
to c5 and now the cagey King to g2 down
upon is kramnik but he's saying what are
you going to do to improve your position
and be very careful I might hit you in
different directions how exactly is not
yet clear but he does have a plan of
sending his G part of the board and if
you think ramnik will not do it that you
have not been watching gromek in this
form this game is incredibly sharp so
much more to go and move 30 only though
10 moves before the time control both in
a heavy time pressure as we speak this
is a wild one
my nerves for both players sorry what
was the idea if okay so the kingi - the
idea was that if we wanted to play
Bishop c5 last moves but there was Queen
a1 yes that's exactly right well I don't
know is that a certain point because the
Essex is hanging in the end right right
maybe you have something better I don't
know this was a tricky I understand what
you're saying that you would be
delighted as white to be able to
establish exactly you can choose a
better move after King G - potentially
well just a second g5 is a very
attractive move right so let's just see
what is wrong with that
Bishop h3 comes to my mind is one
potential downfall of that name correct
there's no threat sorry because obi-wan
is covered so you can just play Queen f6
and win the game correct because let me
name one check rook comes back to I
can't back rank maybe so why you
oh there's Knight g4 there's Knight g4
and be careful there's f2 you can never
play Queen takes d4 because of f2
hanging and that's right and you're not
in time - don't whoops the Queen does a
great job there okay and then you got me
but maybe Queen have six can we continue
maybe my thinking for is an improvement
on your idea yeah Knight g4 did you snip
upon so same thing Queen takes e4 Queen
takes off - and me and if Bishop takes
then Queen a one track same line except
we're up upon oh very good thing - yes
yes well you'll lose the c6 pawn but
you'll take this position at the moment
two parts to me oh yes that's
complicated
that's why good I like this move King GG
- with tux your king away and now
there's 55 perhaps as a threat
absolutely not to mention oops excuse me
so we do have this position
kingi - we're taking all the defense
away from our pieces so what did you now
with Bishop g5 is a big threat for for
vice
exactly exactly and rook da just walks
right into that Bishop g4 loop there was
a fantastic fantastic move exactly was
that kind of just make sure you have no
checks just make you have to think about
the position and and now what do you do
it's it's always great it's such a it's
a typical thing with players that they
always want to do something right I want
to do something what do I do to threaten
something what do I do to threaten
something and often when you create
concrete threats on the board your
opponent as a super GM will say well I
see your threat I answer it and in fact
Levon Aronian made this point to me the
exact point he said one of the worst
things is just giving a strong player as
problems to solve concrete problems
because that's what he's trained to do I
will solve this problem next thing I saw
this problem if it's not an insolvent
Alaba one then I will so solve it but if
you make a move and say your turn how do
you improve the position what is your
intention now you have to stop and think
what do I really want to do and what are
my opponent's possibilities and now that
he doesn't have something very concrete
to solve yet to solve the potential the
things that scare you and that is harder
to do than here's a problem solve it
here's a problem solve it kingi to
secures everything doesn't necessarily
threaten anything maybe it does for in
Bishop g5 but it leaves it up in the air
so efficiently five is a g4 you don't
know what's coming you make a move now
my maduro is playing the move rook to e8
which ii high is a strong move and g5
I'm looking at Bishop there's a good
question what do you do about this
particular move in this moment as g5 now
hits FF 6 through to f7 and we got also
wonder about that c6 pawn it looks like
I guess we I guess we could move the
knight and then if Knight f7 we have
Queen takes f2 is that like survivable
at the end well question in this
particular case the the reason why King
g2 was so sweet
is that and when the king was on g1 I
was checkmated after this move now I can
grab the piece and love this Bishop on
d3 could
rolls the square and I'm just a piece up
it would be pretty happy with that out
right
so the night cannot move to g4 probably
has to move to the site of the board you
had mentioned Maurice ideas of g3 g4
kickin that night you know completely
out of the game and you know if we get
some position f7 is actually held on to
by the bishop and the what exactly but
what if I take the Queen what do you do
Bishop me one this should be one on the
board for a second that looks very the
engine saying that it's not good what is
oh no it's changing its mind okay we can
probably can we bail out with Queen f2
and f6 Bishop walking up to an f6 aha
with a fork of the two pieces yeah that
way I don't know a counter tactic excuse
me let's see there's a there is this
Muji for yeah that looks like a star
move because if I just to your point
Jennifer if I do take the bishop you're
right
black will win no nobody for now yeah
follow the line the knight has to go
back because you taking a piece you just
lose your knight and now you get to play
the tempo gaining Bishop takes and g5
after work but let's let's move to the
actual game because Kramnik did not play
Bishop g5 he played another quiet move
to h3 trying to keep everything out of
that square and I love King g2 but this
may be a an over finesse you kind of
need to move h3 no he did not interview
five it turns out was a fantastic move
Bishop c5 was strong but this h3 yes
what he's in time pressure right so now
we talk about pressure again right where
they have it there there it move 31
they're more 31 so he's in time pressure
right now and he's still got to make
nine moves and now we talk again about
this concept
pressure what do you do when you're
under heavy pressure sometimes you can
go straight and just play regular and
not worry about it or do you get safe
you get conservative we get to see the
character of the players in a very
dynamic pressure field intense situation
and he's gone with h3 and he's again
second time to his opponent said what
are you going to do how do you change
the position for the better and that in
and of itself is a very serious
challenge yeah what is my materials plan
we're talking about how to attack and
it's we can't help it right well how
does white kill him how does why kill me
that's what my major I was looking at
and then suddenly the guy makes another
movement you go well what am I going to
do how do I resolve the situation it's
an incredible psychological ploy I think
incurring crime makes case as an
experienced veteran fighting this
position he's saying I'm just gonna keep
making these waiting move these
creepy-crawly moves that improve my
position my position right you change
your pieces let's say you change your
pieces for the better and if you just
start randomly amassing pawns and
weakening squares I'm gonna jump on you
I think this is a very dangerous
situation objectively maybe not in the
best move Bishop g5 is very strong but
it's dangerous to solve problems then
the guy's not even presenting you right
this is going to be a very tall task
when I'm at zero let's see if he can
pull it off exactly well trying to
decipher the ideas behind the move h2 h3
one thing that we're all attracted to of
course is winning material so maybe
Ladda mayor would love to capture the
spot on c6 but he sees this move Bishop
g4 which traps White's Queen
so by playing the move h2h excuse me by
playing the move h2 h3 we first of all
we guard the square g4 setting them up
for the potential of 96 but more and
more salient is exactly what Maurice is
saying do you black have a plan of what
you want to do in this position white
may even have a threat Bishop g5 I'm
really attracted to but even the move
Bishop h6 could really cause serious
problems on the dark squares as well as
well as Knight takes c6 winning back the
pawn this rook on b7 is huge
Maurice this is just a very nice
attacking position for Vladimir we
should note another position of critical
importance this game with zingaran and
Sergei Kuryakin and ding did win this
pawn and is in this position Knight to
e7 and take a look at this night this
night was once on it was to be 192 c4 b
6 d 5 e 7 9 f5 King e6 Knight to g3
Bishop d8 night to H 1 we got a night
store and in fact happening right now as
the night is going completely to the
other side and after a 5 then King to e2
it is clear that the knight did this
entire maneuver knowing that this Paul
was on a dark square along a light
Square in the dark where Bishop couldn't
fight it there's gonna go to f2 and then
take this pawn however there's things
that could happen with these pawns on
this side of the board and ding Lorena
did take advantage of the moment to play
the move
d5 what an impressive looking array of
pawns we see here and these this looks
like a study type situation yes you've
seen the studies with see what a4 and
all the pawns go down and you sack one
and you cite the other and you sack and
then you queen doesn't seem so easy to
make this work in this position but wow
they are still fighting it out will ding
Lorraine he needs to win is that
desperate to win this game if he wins
the game then he has an outside chance
so we'll see as car yakin is thinking I
can't afford to lose and a draw I think
also fails for him oh well if Fabi loses
then he's in with a draw and a momager
of draw a loss that is loss as well so
there's all kind of complications in a
position in all kind of complications
while the parents are concerned in a
situation where there complications on
the board with time pressure afoot and
we do have from Bobby Doerr if you play
Bishop takes f2 yeah whoa he takes F -
oh absolutely
oops wrong board sorry here we go h2 h3
was supposed to be this nice solid
improving move and Bishop takes f2 smack
sacrificing a piece now the whole idea
is this Queen defends the
- pun so let's take a look at what
Mamedov has mine Queen takes c2 well
it's time to go have to check or Bishop
takes h3 check right yes yes we have to
so now let's say I move my king we're
gonna see takes right takes and there's
a rook takes e5 so at the end of the day
it's a that's a lot of pawns that's the
basket of pawns isn't it well but it's
four versus two that's a very good
exchange say you I thought Shaq was in
real trouble after this move h3 h3 was
not it h3 it was great to generalize
like I did but it turns out concretely
bishop if Suzu was a positive this
possibility and now he's been bail he
can bail out with this position but is
he work a seven looks forced Rana looks
best right
but what is this this looks this is just
a right this is a very good Bishop
versus rook and pawn wait would you just
do don't you're dropping the C pawn if
you do yeah okay fine but how are you
gonna put the bishop on d5 just gonna
give the pawn up yeah I'll just give up
the pawn and I'll just say look my
bishop just protects everything
so you're the worst thing you're saying
mummy-ji rob has brilliantly forced the
draws exactly is that's exactly what I'm
saying
house trace is a dead draw actually
comes official Bobby will you know the
position and see if Greek might wanna
draw no let's take a look at Bobby's
position because we were I was very
favorable towards his position let's see
what has happened when we left it we
were just about these parts we have been
looking at some very nice exchanged
sacrifices which look frankly very
promising for for black have you said no
I don't have to sacrifice anything
I'm just plays safe and solid rope d8
Bishop g3 this is
nice bishop I must say posting up right
here on g3 rookie to g5 artificially
isolating the e5 pawn it means that in
the future there can be no f4 push King
f1 king f7 this is all looking good
Bishop c7 he's offering a repetition
he's probably typically was in time
pressure no they're basically playing on
the increment yeah right 57 okay fabbi
if you I would have repeated once a
hundred percent just to see what my
opponent is doing as well with the move
rookie but it depends if Bobby was ahead
on time then repeating may just give
give his opponent a breather right fair
enough
but okay again he says find a move but
he took his work off the a far I like
the rook on the a file I like the rook
on the a file a lot in fact hmm okay
that's a little confounding I think that
Bishop would go from g3 did these six
was a real plus for white Oh without
question the bishop on g3 was a passive
spectator on the g3 on the d6 where it's
doing all kinds of good things including
me simply defending the e5 pawn and
disrupting blacks position and
furthermore it's you know Bobby didn't
take any of those ideas to sacrifice so
we're like a couple different I know
that's right and we do currently have
this position and Maurice you're over
there doing a dance what's going on
well it looks like Fabia's get getting
some pressure in the game and I think
it's gonna be exciting to see as it
looks like Grichuk has made an error
that has allowed Fabiano to get a great
chance in time pressure I let's before
we update that let's go to this position
this one here after d5 9f2 king d6 85
King takes a ninety for this night man I
mean give it some overtime money because
this time this this Knight took hit I
said be you on d2 c4 down to b6 then to
d5 then where did he go from there then
the way then it went f6 f6
for G 3 H 1 f 2 now e for this Bishop is
completely anemic on the square this
night a fantastic piece can always go
back but he has to be concerned about
any kind of push on this side but I get
the feeling you guys at this position
might be a positional drum might be just
a draw a fortress and a drove for ding
is not great while Kuryakin will have to
hope and pray about possibilities on the
other boards and that would be quite
problematic indeed but back to fabi's
game west position we did see we did see
this big moment in the game rook what
was it Bishop back to be one after me
after the oh you were here you were here
in the Pacific rook ac8 rook a1 taking
over the file rook to d8 Bishop to b1 a
little unusual I think time pressure is
definitely rearing its head and then
this move rook to a3 and this was where
we saw an explosion by Fabi d4 on board
undermining the pawn chain and now this
one has indeed exploded look at these
pawn capture as possible
this Knight about to leap into the game
the move d3 that's a win very much on
tap and Fabiano Caruana
taking the bull by the horns he might
just say what we say about tiebreaker
tiebreaks and shove it because if I win
the game then no more discussion he
needs to defeat Gris truth and not worry
about these permutations with ampersands
and slashes /no forget about that it's
called karana defeats Gris shook and
makes it all the way to playing against
Magnus Carlsen and if he wins this game
remember he will have lost two games ago
then come back roaring with a victory
and a victory and yeah as we talk about
this all the time if you're gonna be the
Challenger let everybody look and say
that yeah that guy's the Challenger yeah
he don't backdoor your way into it let
everybody know of course I'm the man who
should be challenging the world champion
yeah Magnus sweat a little is he's
eating his popcorn watching his games
cool take us through it Maurice so we've
just seen this breakout with the move d4
so how would it go after a b a b c three
takes d4 i'm assuming we're gonna see
Knight takes d4 recapturing the pond and
okay you have a runaway passer c4 but
after rook a7 what
what's the follow-up that fabbi has
envisioned I'm just trying to figure out
how you got to this position I thought
that the rook on e two went to a two
I was looking at I think your position
is work on us Bishop was already on b1
so the right so we went look a one rook
d8 Bishop b1 then we went rook d7 r okay
- I thought I think it's no seven rook a
three-way okay so rook d7 rook a3 okay
that looks like a wasted note now that
now D for now d4 oh that that's a
massive difference I apologize I thought
the rook I was envisioning that the move
Bishop b1 was making way for the rook on
he - to move over to a2 so now this is
the position okay so all that makes all
the difference in the world because if
you take on d4 now the knight recaptures
it's a temple against the rook and he's
still menacing C 3 and C 2 oh my moves
five more moves to get to time control
and what happened my clock is saying
it's it's 11:59 our time that means it's
only one minute to time control oh well
actually they've been getting increment
so they get they get extra time right I
see how does that work they have very
little time Greece are playing on the
internet just a few moves no time
control work on e - a - pinky 494 Ricky
yeah D for D 3 is a winning threat so
takes on d4 1934 work on e - a - now
Knight went back to c6 trying to round
up the e5 pawn yeah that's another juicy
one ok yes for Bishop b4 makes sense
very logical I'll take on e5 there you
go
and now after Bishop takes c6 we're take
c6 Bishop b5 um well it's all fabulous
this is marvelous and when control we
can take a look at the other games
because it's bishops of opposite color
but the most dangerous pawn in the
position is this past
z pond and definitely Grisham trying to
clock claw his way through a drop that
this is great news for Fabiana fans
Bishop is alphas color no losing chances
and winning chances well but you know
[ __ ] Rob's that color if this starts to
lean draw a blockade on c2 for example
that is unbreakable mm-hmm then it's not
that great if the other boards were more
explosive but thankfully those boards
have settled down and it looks like ding
Lorena is not going to win the game
despite being up a pawn and it would be
irrelevant in fact it was the most
important thing the most important thing
he doesn't well yes I mean he can win so
you can win this pawn back whenever he
likes
that's not that's true you're right he
has to be careful about this a4 but but
yes you're right he is up to pawns but
it's not very easy to break through here
and make make it work we'll see is he's
still working hard but even if he wins
the game ding we're in this result would
be great for Fabi as long as this one
this one is only a draw if this one is
only a draw then my Madeira and it looks
to the world that it should be a draw
then Madeira will only draw and Kraken
not win with a draw fabi's in and that's
still fine by him so this is extremely
important that he doesn't matter if he
doesn't win anymore it's looking less
necessary for him to win I should say
less necessary for him to win because
these two games now have petered out
into positions that should be not
winnable for my material or for kayaking
and crucially when he makes the time
control he can get up take a look at
those games see what he needs to do and
you know he'll see that well it's likely
you know gonna get him that spot and
when I say likely I'm not talking 70% I
really really really like the way that
fabbi has conducted himself in this game
especially the position that he
currently has achieved bishops of
opposite color he's on the sunny side of
the position and it's like he's got the
draw in the pocket essentially yes he
doesn't have a lot of time to look at
the other game so this is so critical
because if it wasn't for the fact that
these games seem to be petering out he
would mean that potential winning
chances yes so just the way that he's
playing this tournament and ever since
that lost the champion and here again
now keep in mind these gentlemen know
each other very very very well similar
in age 9 to 5 17 draws they've really
taken the measure of one another and
gosh knows how many rapid and blitz
games that they've competed against one
another in Grantchester they know each
other's strengths and weaknesses very
very well that's 31 classical games wow
that's just classical games we're not
talking on as you said about the rapid
and the blitz games but the classical
games will be the one of import clearly
Magnus with the edge there but he knows
Fabiano Caruana would be a big
josepho me yes we've seen these two
battle right here in st. Louis and
Sinquefield couples who can forget that
game where father one is black the
double King Harbor Magnus failed
sacrifice on f7 right and note about if
they do face off in the World
Championship it everybody's gonna be
reviewing all of their battles of course
any day 13 when you talk about the
street this thing feels Cup streak that
Fabiano had one of the most
extraordinary things about that +7
result that that seven wins in a row was
the eighth game was actually he was
white against Magnus and remarkably
enough Abby had a winning continuation
in that game the street could have
continued and then in the final game
against Hikaru ABI also had a winning
continuation
it would have been Fisher s proportions
if he had just won those positions as
well so it was just an extraordinary and
in criticizing the guy yes no it
catapult him to number two in the world
in extra and I believe depending on the
outcome of everything should
fabbi not lose and even potentially win
I think you'd probably be the number two
player in the world and it would just be
one of those things that yes I see
you've got you you pulled up the oh
there's a lot of points ahead of them
like 15 no kidding also game points in
this tournament but in the end the
number two that you want to be is the
guy who gets to play Magnus girls but I
wasn't saying it would have been very
appropriate how do you given the number
two in the world you know you want to
see a world championship match where the
two top players face off well give him
some time you still got the tournament
anything are you playing thank you
coming up in April traditionally not a
good one to try to win rating points
because he's gonna be higher rated than
a lot of the players in the field but
you never know right exploring that and
we actually have players who are gonna
be in that tournament it's
we can see the list but the big three
will be playing in the US Championship
in just a few weeks here in st. Louis
the big three of course being Fabiana
rowana Hikaru Nakamura and Wesley so but
it's also last year's runner up many
people are excited to see Alexander
ownership he's actually entering the
world chess Hall of Fame this year so
congratulations to Alex he'll be
inducted that's right Tech coach and
then we've got a ray Robson Sam Shanklin
both on the gold medal Olympic winning
team with the United States and Baku
sorry we've got saying it was his own
version of Cobian who also really
impressed last year almost winning the
championship ahead of the big three
exactly
also some youngsters Geoffrey Jean honor
[Music]
also have Alex Lenderman and another
youngster I wander a lot beyond that the
player was really excited to see what's
gonna happen from him top junior talent
absolutely but one big God is not
playing this yeah so he won't be playing
Yaroslav jariabek who did so well last
year and place for slew is another
contender as well as viata zoria a
player that we haven't seen in this
championship for quite a while so
that'll be interesting and of course and
speaking of a gotta camp ski who we
won't see an issue a championship here
we do see em in the 1969 teen 96 feet a
world champion which was the last time
of American competed for the world
championship in a failed effort against
my master anatoly karpov so we're gonna
see if Viviano
22 years later can do better than can
ski in london one of the things that's
very intriguing i think i've i've come
across in my day
much more superstitious grandmasters
they're not you have lucky pet
especially
not the lucky shirt no I mean people
really do believe you know like they
take a walk they did their exercise they
did the routine they won they did it
again they want now suddenly it's like
I'm gonna keep repeating everything I've
done for every day you know the routine
of exercise walking and whatever it is
that superstition they cling to it well
that probably has a positive function in
chess preparation yes because you know
you're you're so mentally drained
keeping some things the same yes it's a
great idea so even though the
superstition is not accurate it may be
like makes you more relaxed because you
don't have to think about what to eat
for breakfast right you're lucky omelet
you don't have to think about the recipe
I'm all for it over to you Maurice what
have you got for us well the big news is
they have all many time controls so time
control has passed move 40 is no longer
impending and they can now sit down and
inspect the end games to see what the
real situation is qur'anic and take a
walk look at the other boards also look
at what his situation is his position as
you mentioned yes is definitely better
and he's the one trying to win that game
does he have enough in that bitch'll
opposite call anything well thankfully
he has two rooks on the board and that
does alter the calculation the calculus
of well how you assess positions like
that it's not just bishops and pawns so
that one is there this one between
Sargon Kraken and England doesn't look
like it will be a draw because there's
no way for black to break through
there's just no moves to make that gets
black in the best he could do is somehow
maybe sacrifice this pawn it looks as
though this protection is on this side
he could play a three but that gives him
one less break and then how do you get
in the nine can just shuffle back and
forth this bishop can't improve itself
to get on the other side imagine for
example putting a bishop here it could
stalemate the King but even if it did
that it wouldn't even matter how do you
get past the light-square blockade looks
as though Kraken should draw this game
bad news for ding Loretta and Kuryakin
as far B's in a great situation though
only question then for Fabiano Caruana
is this position chronic mum is Europe
only mahmud Europe it looks like in
witness position exactly I don't see how
it is otherwise can he pull it off
though the pawns don't look that
menacing yes can he somehow get
connected passers even if he got an
extra pawn it's gonna be something one
pawn on this side as these pawns seem to
hold these three at bay and even then
the rook should be a formidable defender
with the king the dark squares seems as
though at this moment the bookies are
saying
Fabiano Caruana in one magnus carlsen is
seeming quite prescient in this moment I
think it's better than 70% now better
than 95% it is two pawns and I could see
ways that mammi could make some inroads
but you know yeah the two in the
exchange I don't think that he has any
losing chances whatsoever I mean it's
very very hard for me to envision a
scenario where you know blacks Knight is
basically unassailable right if black
plays h5 and f6
I mean black has a fortress but then the
question is can he press they're going
back again to the game of a fabbi for a
moment Maurice this could all be very
academic because it really looks to me
like a very good a my Derek dare I say
close to winning position for for black
what exact how exactly is Griffith
supposed to defend his position I don't
see a good defence of my setup why he
has to guard the c2 square at all costs
he's gonna lose the pawn and for sure at
least it looks like that pawn can't
really be protected and deal with the
threat of the pawn going down the board
to c3 the thing here though yes I would
say is white does have his King in the
mix right so you'll have to break down
both rooks and Bishop and the King okay
right so if the King is going to hang
out the whole time on that side as well
he should be able to set up some kind of
c2 action especially your pollen gets to
c3 better than Bishop to d3
and Bishop to c2 idiom to play Bishop a4
an Bishop to see to put the bishop on c2
and then the question would be to you
how do you break that blockade and
remember the rook is all set as well
give me a specific mission boy fish
survey for let's just okay let's just
test the water so to speak yeah engine
doesn't like it at all give me a check
first of all I don't think you're going
to go King e4 you may be walking into a
mating though I'm not gonna make you
happy with so you're gonna go King e2
okay actually King e4 loses two losses
my rook on a7 that looks like he for a
rookie one chick and then I have to go
to d4 and it should be three check and
there goes the room whoops
that's a skewer that's a nice one so
you've gotta have to drop back either
Ted e - so II - okay let's do it
e - now let's say I'm just trying to
simply win let me go
rook here okay so now I can well my idea
is to play C three and maybe rook D to
check on a good day so that means if I
play rook d7 you may be trade and C 2
and C 3 and then I want to play rook be
to check see if I can go pawn to c3 and
look to be to check lice very good - I'm
telling you something's weird okay let's
listen is really really inspiring line
let's watch that line though what which
one would you want to play rip d7 did
you want to play i just noticed a
variation sorry let's play rugby salmon
just for a second okay
I'll trade and I'll play seats OOP
pardon me take take now play C 3 with
the IRA and now I play Bishop back
Bishop back okay so after rook takes
you'll get your pawn bishop here perhaps
let's just see I mean what is what is
your your breakthrough well I was gonna
this one a Bishop d3
Bishop d3 so let me take that last move
back so if I bring my king to d4 but you
can understand my feeling I think you
know obviously a to result game and more
than you know but in my era
but let's take a quick break as we find
out if Bob piano camerado will challenge
Magnus Carlsen in the fall were the last
round of the candidates and we'll be
back in just a few minutes to test
[Music]
a moment comes in chess when you need to
test yourself at a different level chess
24 premium offers the tools that you
need to reach your maximum potential
from hundreds of interactive video
lessons to becoming part of the chess 24
community you can analyze with friends
or coach your students live you get
twenty four by seven coverage of chess
news and events access to premium
analysis and commentary and the chance
to interact with grandmasters and other
top players and coaches get advice from
the best and even challenge them to a
battle be the best chess player you can
be it's time to level up your game with
chess 24 premium membership as the st.
Louis Chess Club celebrates its 10th
anniversary the US Championships
returned to st. Louis for the 10th
straight year
this April America's best players
descend on st. Louis to play for the
country's top honor Wesley so and Sabina
Pfizer will be defending their
championships as they face an all-star
field
don't miss America's best battle it out
at the st. Louis chess club celebrating
10 years of promoting teaching and
playing the game of chess for tickets
and more information go to st. Louis
chess club org
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to today in tests where we
have breaking news the game between
Sergey Karjakin and Bing Lauren has been
drawn that means that Sergey will not be
repeating his challenge to magnus
carlsen only thing that's official is
that ding Lauren will not be the
Challenger absolu in the only player in
this competition to go without a loss in
the entire competition but +1 was not
enough he's now officially at 7 and a
half and he has been knocked out sir
Sergei Kuryakin is still a couple of
blunders by Fabio and Madara they both
have to lose a manager oh yeah for him
to have a chance but his chances have
now been reduced to something maybe
north of 1% Norfolk or maybe we're gonna
check that compass Sergei is gonna do it
with 8 points as it would require most
critically member zero of losing and
even if I be lost my Madeira has to lose
this position as she has better tie
breaks having defeated Kuryakin in round
one that looks like a problem for him
because it doesn't seem as though as
possible from a dear off to blow this
position like Harley is absolutely and
having said that Murray's back over to
you because while we were on break
you found a marvelous continuation for
Fabiano which appeared quite frankly to
clinch this move Bishop d7 was not a
good move by Alexander Grichuk yes and
we should point out this final position
by the way this one the pawn on a3 looks
quite impressive in the Diggler endgame
but the problem is now there are no palm
breaks on this side there's no pawn
break through C for this night just have
to shuffle back and forth and forget
about this pawn don't give him the
chance to ever play efore if the king is
sitting on d5 and there's just no way to
break through so this one is a
dead-dead draw but back to this one yes
this position here we're talking about
Bishop to d7 remember I wanted to put
the bishop on c2 and try to hold off
your life as if these seven goes in a
different direction it says I'm going to
get counter play against your eponymous
this one or this one most likely this
one and attack the mess out of this pawn
the problem with this line however is
the move Bishop to f4 check does create
problems for where this king wants to go
obviously we mentioned the King doesn't
really want to go up board because it
will be challenged and maybe getting
into checkmating net but if it backs up
for example to e 2 and then rook over
the problem is if you now leave with a
move like rook to a6 it is indeed
possible to play check forcing the King
backwards let's say let's say here
getting on a light square and then to
sacrifice this and then play for c3 and
this one is got an escort c2 is coming
no way to stop that fc-1 Queens win a
piece and you might have this one bond
for the bishop that's not going to be
nearly enough that's going to be a
disastrous position for white so this
position would be winning Bishop f4
check is indeed a strong looking move
with the plan of moving the rook away
and then push the baby home this pawn is
still hanging he could take it at any
time but at the moment this doesn't seem
as though Grichuk he's trying to get
counter play but it doesn't seem like
it's nearly enough in the bishop going
off in the wrong direction Wow huge and
then you know of course mentioning the
game that all eyes are also turning to
and that's between Vladimir Kramnik and
Shaq Mahmood ro
Shaq was able to give up an exchange for
two pawns
how serious are Shaq's chances I'm sure
he stands better but can he pull out a
win in that game where he's oh you're
asking me yes sir I thought you were
looking at it yourself because I know
you know this position is nothing this
is this is just what do you what do you
get the problem is that this rook is a
pain in the neck I mean the work is
always going to be checking you all day
and you're gonna have to constantly
build fortresses to deal with this rook
and that is a big problem
the rook will also get behind pawns so
you have to keep your knight on this
square and somehow find a way to make
progress that doesn't change your
position so that is a major major
challenge for for black in this position
the rook is just too active can start
marauding in the position this is gonna
create too much danger I don't think he
has any chance of winning this position
well let's get a confirmation on that
because we have a very very excited man
on the phone call Jennifer welcome to
the show let us know your name and why
you're so excited hi I'm Zach from
Kentucky I just wanted to talk about how
this best candidates tournament that I
have seen in my lifetime and I am a bit
sad though because I tried to find you
guys for like the first two days of the
tournament and then I was like I guess
they're not interested in chess nowadays
so I I just didn't even check until
today and so I'm really glad to see
y'all today
shoutout to all of you guys and Aronian
and kramnik i know that they are
probably very disappointed with their
results however I am so happy for how
they just they played every game they
tried to get every bit of juice from the
position roni ins g4 against Cara whatta
I mean just crazy just just the chest
that they played was awesome the results
that they got I'm sure they're not very
happy with but as a spectator I am just
enthralled first of all thank you for
your discovery and finding that we are
indeed on the air and have been since
around the last five rounds that's right
so this today in chess we came back for
ya the climax of the event but yeah we
we weren't here actually for the first
few rounds but of course we were
following it you were actually doing
some covered with the chest bras so yes
the chest world was transfixed on this
tournament and we're glad that you
missed us but and to your point Zach I
you to your two points I I absolutely
agree this has been just a fantastic
fantastic event better than I think
anybody could have possibly hoped for
the games have been a thrill and
Vladimir Kramnik I think has almost
stolen the show completely as you say
he's not going to be proud of his result
but his play is fantastic and well on
star we magnus carlsen who has had three
successful title match victories twice
against anand and then of course last a
couple years ago against carjacking here
the Grandmaster title at age 13 and 148
days does does Sergey still hold the
record however for the youngest
Grandmaster ever yes
yes he does okay but that is a fantastic
record thirteen I remember when Bobby
Fischer became a grandmaster fifteen and
then I thought okay now it's possible
that anybody would ever be does record
and look at that Judith Bogart you
mentioned and obviously Magnus but a
three-time world champion Magnus Carlsen
waiting first challenger and it looks
increasingly likely we don't want to
jinx him of course but it does look like
fabbi is going to do it and last I
checked with the youngest Grand Master
in the world is a wonderly young current
youngest Grand Master who will be of
course playing in our US Championship
okay let's take a look at how possibly
Shaq might be able to pull off still yet
a victory yeah like oh crap make make
some errors for instance right so we've
just seen this last move Bishop g2 with
a very obvious threat of capturing this
pawn on e4 let's assume just for the
moment that the rook would post up to
defend this pawn now imagine I would
play King e6 just on a good day I want
to push these pawns g5 and h4 and I
don't as maurice was mentioning this
room
could quickly swing behind the h-bond
so I move my king up to e6 just to
sidestep that possibility now white
white to play we need to make a poor
choice for poor choice a poor choice for
Kramnik would be a poor choice like
bishop a6 that would give up the
pressure that white is having on the h5
pawn and suddenly yes g5 with the idea
of h4 and suddenly chances appear maybe
that's very to say the c6 but you mean
you really want to go after this guy
like okay I will give it to you I will
push h4 let's take it take it
now again you know I'm pardon me black's
pawn shacks pawn is just three tempie
away from promotion you you're gonna
push this and also I'm still maintaining
I'm keeping this rook honest as well by
maintaining pressure I mean I could play
Bishop c8
not so sure let's say f7 I want to go to
have five in the player case our go f5
Bishop f5 aha
so that after h3 you still get it was
funny because I was trying to with my
move King e6 I was trying to get away
from that rook coming nicely active and
I can keep checking as well and then and
if you go to if you go to eight sub and
you go to eight six then I do the same
check Oh
eventually I'll play like this yeah okay
so even this case has not brought black
success rook rook is Ron Broussard nasty
there are the best defenders but they
can be very active yes and that that
rook in that position is just waiting
for you to loosen the position somewhat
that you can jump all over you and even
with the moves I play which is not
necessarily the best moves right but you
do have to watch out yeah you're just
giving me some mm rope a little bit by
the way by the way even in that line you
notice there is a possibility we do look
at that as as like a real counter play
shot but the fact that Y can also go
after that week C pawn yeah is is
something Black has to constantly
analyze as well although you won't lose
the game because the guy takes the C
pawn but or or I will also point out
sorry back that up a second I went after
the C pawn directly this Bishop c8 idea
is another is another defensive
technique so let's play the Bishop a6
move you say so bad
g5 and now what about Bishop c8 instead
checking at once yeah you didn't get
your h4 move in yet I sure have not no
you know that was the measurement at 5
and then the bishop on every time oh
that is actually a very good square it
turns out for the bishop you're so good
guys it's hard for you to make a bad
move all those variants hmm not looking
good we should end the conversation yeah
let's see if Abby can and the converse
is the way we did see this move Bishop
to f4 check on the board and it should
be pointed out King to e4 very
concretely is not a move you want to
play that's called a nice little help
mate after a rook check and King moves
and then suddenly there's this little
business of mate in one on the board
very nice thank you very much for the
gift chances of that move being played
zero zero zero zero unless each to this
isn't heavy blitz mo but well thanks for
gays chances of winning the
and now now the relay in fact under
attack and you would expect the work to
move out of the way an eyeball this
Bishop but he does have to calculate the
reality of this pawn coming under attack
and that he will be sacrificing for this
Bishop in order to get the play he wants
so that move d8 route d8 and now this
work cannot do it obviously because it's
defending the bishop this rook leaves
the King behind as the King will be
driven to the back row after this check
and where do you put it you won't put it
on a light square but and you don't want
to go here of course because of checking
and losing the bishop directly so King
back and now you're about to take this
pawn but wait a second there's also
another reality
there's also another reality that's
trying to win the game but what if you
play check huh isn't this just a draw
yes that ends the game immediately
perpetual that's that simply ends the
game right so you could try to win with
taking may be optimal but this is just
now having secured the draw in his hands
to see this position that means
everything would rest on the outcome of
the one remaining game other than this
one this one back here and I'm sure if
Robbie will keep on playing because he
hasn't seen resolution in this position
yet chronic might hang a fork of some
kind and impress under pressure although
it looks very unlikely but he will have
a draw if he wants it by just repeating
but again you were talking optimal there
for a second
rook d8 I don't you you showed that
tactical variation that after rook a6
you sacrifice the exchange with rook b2
and rook d7 is winning so yeah so if
you're if this move rook on a2 after
rook d8 rook on a2 to a6 is a losing
move for white he can't play it what's
he going to do Maurice what's the what's
the alternative this pawn is scorching
hot it doesn't have to be any other
right here maybe just rook c2 because
you can't play rook c7 raro that's a
bishop
so rook c2 in order to stop this threat
of C 4 C 3 followed by rook B to check
rotates exactly so rook c7 oh sorry
okay look see - I beg your pardon rook
takes pawn so that's just a very nice
extra pawn and then Bishop is misplaced
on d7 TSU Bishop b8 is a threat right
now bishop to be eight right yes so I
was driving to protect driving the rook
away from the protection of this bishop
how do you how do you even start
defending this precisely I'm trying to
figure it out because I have to move
your Bishop to stop it should be a yeah
but what else but then check this one
there's a little c3 action exactly with
ideas of rook be to as well as rook d2
jack and if rook takes pawn then then it
should be your eight we're married yes
it's mazing three yeah I think that
Bobby is just gonna try to win because
on the off chance that Kramnik gets in
the time pressure and blunders his
senses of losing her absolutely right so
you might as well just try to finish the
game and then end everything right well
while we were on break I was talking
with Christian and we were both like
incredibly impressed we think that fabbi
played a flawless game today I mean he
maintained incredible calm and you know
if he manages to maneuver into this a to
result position it's just fantastic and
a beautiful beautiful game no I think it
says definitely his best played game of
the event I mean he's had some amazing
games but when you look over this game
and you replay the game you you can't
help but be impressed people are gonna
be replaying these games
generations yeah this is a cleaner
affair yes absolutely if you like
control chess and I do and just stopping
anything the other guy has right keep
everything solid and just go go go and
then just eventually I'll play and
definitely will be his most controlled
and clean victory he was never in any
real danger that I can remember his name
and to be in a must-win situation well
I'm surprised to be in a pressure field
situation and just play your game that
is the secret to handling pressure just
play like yourself and handle your
business and then walk out of there no
matter what everybody else is screaming
about or worried about I got to say the
game against Aronian though it was
pretty saucy and that one will be
probably the spectacular game I think
gonna be published in a lot of places
because this one is this kind of like
you know bizarre Z colors mmm it was
technical and and very good by him if he
wins but that one yes was wild with the
night before possibility and yeah and
all that chaos and an ending with rook
eight six check yeah that one was to me
my favorite win of his and the crappy
game and the Kramnik a crappy game was
wobba crime they could have stopped the
energy if he had just chosen to write by
the way Shaq has come up with a very
nifty idea you were mentioning that this
knight on e5 kind of hobbled by the
necessity of defending the pawn on c6
well Shaq said well let me redirect that
night he's played the move Knight f3
with the idea that he can bring his
kingdom five as well as playing Knight
g5 and just focusing all his pieces
against this pawn on e4 he's more than
willing to trade the e4 pawn for the c6
bond so that they can get a three-to-one
majority and after Knight f3 for example
a near ideal situation for Shaq would be
something like this where after the move
teeny 5 he'll play Bishop takes e4 the
most beautiful diagonal for that Bishop
and he'll end up with a three versus one
majority Oh
pardon me you like that better than I 5
yes yes give you more yeah and I'm just
I'm just dreaming of creating two
connected passed pawns and taking like
this and this aged pawn with this Bishop
looking at that scrumptious square yes
so there so this was a nice nice move by
trying its ease trying and I do believe
we have a move on the board no I'm just
analyzing the variation that the trick
though is this move Bishop to c4 check
King kami easy fine and if you go up the
board then this move rook down behind
and and if you simply take the pawn yes
by the way this is it's a big threat
nice little mate threat yes King takes
an authorship to d3 check for check
chases you back you have to go backwards
and a lot of us work to come in here you
know keep go after this pawn though yes
this one for this woman under different
circumstances not as active King in this
position but and that's really
significant and that's really
significant be king that means y can
organize the defense they just giving
King c6 I'm not sure what was wrong with
rook c6 looks like there's nothing wrong
with it I can go check and came back and
if I take on g3 there's a take here this
check in some yes you can't go here
because of the discovered possibilities
right losing one of the two whichever
one right so working six check you have
to leave the pawn and now he does still
have these two connected processors but
no you're not winning that position
though exactly alright back to the game
with Fabiano that is for all the marbles
a win in this game would win the well he
would be Challenger let me refresh my
board and get up-to-date with the
players I believe we have seen rook c2
because again we had analyzed this move
rook a6 to a winning sacrifice for fabbi
so rooks rook the eight rooks e2s on the
board and now rook takes b4 not just
clipping upon but also White has has
been thrown on the defensive and c3 as
well as Bishop b8 there are concrete
threats that I just don't see how Sasha
is gonna do all of them how what what do
the engines say well there is there is a
big variation yes a huge variation in
the position right now a very big
variation after rook da truck see to
that White has to deal with this move
rook to g1 maybe winning on the spot
this move might win a piece on the spot
I'm not sure
Bobby is inspecting it you couldn't
obviously take on before but this move
could end it all right now what is the
problem for white the problem is lets me
play move like g4 rook to h1 very subtle
move and take a look at why this move
work - h1 if you play a random moves you
play a random move b5 suddenly the move
check your rooks under attack the King
has to retreat and now this rook is
protected black and play King back to e7
attacking the pin piece and you can't
deal with it and there's no rook takes
g2 the rook is not sitting on the g2
square a small nuance but Fabi can find
this Bobby can absolutely find this the
move rook to g1 threatening to take the
pawn the problem being that if you now
take here
rook takes check you can't go to the D
file you can't go here because of check
and you lose the piece so the so now
that means you have to go to the back
row something like came to f1 rook to d2
and now this Bishop is on there heavy
fire and these pieces are gonna stream
in very fast let's put the bishop
somewhere something like Bishop to c6
and now you're getting mated
Johnny ball game what do you do about
this move
hello Magnus rook g1 it's over
it is completely he's a free piece in
his pocket he could take on before I'm
curious because what work takes before
is so obvious looking and there's no
move for white to improve his position
right there's nothing here
so rook before it's very very obvious
and he could just in five seconds I've
just said let me take on before in a
blitz situation so that might mean that
he does see rook to G to group 2 G 1
with a route g2 threat and is inspecting
it since route before is so easy to play
if he sees it I guarantee you it's game
over and I think he sees it because why
else wouldn't just take the pawn exactly
right now and keep playing the game so
we might see rook g1 on the board and
how long in this position and how long
has he been content I were gonna take it
and if - and it doesn't matter King Kiev
- radiation bringing this but the
problem is you know your bishop is is
doing work so this line I don't know
where you're gonna put your Bishop
Bishop to a bishop to a4 is playable and
now this pawn starts to milk down the
board right this this is looking there
those meetings right - how do you get
how do you get behind this this joker
this guy's mean yeah that seat bond is
coming very very fast you got a check
you got a you got a possibility of
coming down and then trading trading
down here
this is dangerous play just a random
move this move b5 and now the move check
you have to take it's a forced race yeah
you have to move push and now you're
threatening Queen mate oh no rook c7
sorry Maurice rook c7 rook t1 check and
then take the rook yeah yeah yeah don't
allow
yes are we gonna play trick a - instead
of C - that looks pretty wonderful as
well everything looks great for black
and these relations and I agree with
Maurice the longer that Bobby thinks
more he's gonna play this hyper accurate
move and you said that's why you love
this game that accuracy that Bobby is
demonstrating absolutely flawless game
he's just playing under pressure oh we
took on the floor it looks like come on
much better he's still much better in
that position but oh gee one was a
fantastic chance that King e7 move was
so counterintuitive at the end of the
line allowing all the discoveries maybe
that was the hard point to find Jennifer
we have a very special guest this time
on a Skype call that's right we are
we're getting ready for a very special
cast but we are previewing it to you
guys because we got Garry Kasparov
joining us in a few minutes so if you
were thinking of taking a break do it
well I mean Gary has actually been
tweeting a lot about the championships
he mentioned that it was a completely
inappropriate tournament Hall that it's
like an arena with all of the people
looking down and the noise must be
horrendous
having said that he's absolutely
enthralled by the games as we all are oh
yeah bring bringing us so much
excitement the players really came to
play it's just so great also to have
Garry Kasparov joining us he's doing
this Bishop before live in the show like
at the Ziegfeld Cup in the championship
absolutely we prefer that but we'll take
a Skype I'm losing my job Jerry what's
the cheer he's so good well I'm sure he
will also share his view as the
Challenger and here he is hello Gary
welcome to the today in chess show hello
Gary
you guys you love chess slaughter
[Laughter]
talking about about waste can win the
game though from the perspectives of
winning the candidates it doesn't matter
because I mean I don't see how manager
can they
so you should you should talk about
winning the tournament and not spending
so much time on just one game do you
want those many easily but you're now
position is still won easily but but
it's it's probably irrelevant because
now we should talk about you know use
chances in his name well let's talk
about it what what about his chances
against Magnus Gary how do you see that
matchup the strengths and the weaknesses
of the players look I don't think we
should talk about Magnus pranks we all
know yeah okay again it's I think his
chances
I would I would rate his chances higher
than kuryakin's it doesn't say much of
course but Magnus and the matches proved
to be Volvo so let me first say few
words about the tournament you mentioned
the conditions
I've been following in the comments by
many players that complain about
everything from the hotel to the
restaurants in the in the venue and I'm
surprised that I don't see the
connection between the those people were
running fee there and the conditions
that they forced clay one of the most
important tournaments of the year but
again that's the that's that's for them
to actually find out but it's a bit odd
that the chess players they cannot you
know add one and one and I have to say
that the quality of the play of this
tournament was probably equal to the
course of the organization I never seen
so many blunders though I have to say
that as I tweeted ones that I think the
game Dhingra shook made me feel
exhilarated because I realized that my
fondest is in st. Louis specially one
against awara
there were nothing compared to what what
you saw there so getting from plus 15 to
0 and if you move that's that was quite
an accomplishment or for the candidates
and also it's important to mention that
all the players study class they just
you know they they have no chance yes
Chronicle a few good games but
eventually he lost his team and
and his game was Khurana you know just
destroyed him that we thought he would
have to give me and compared to others
Fabiana played in a more solid collector
his chances asleep against Kuryakin who
have to say played a very good game
against team but it's important that
Fabiana show that's that's an important
sign and that's what's what you need to
worry to win big tournaments so we
deserve to win the tournament and now
I'm gonna I'm curious what will happen
in the match because as I said bad news
mangoes before was the last night is
Kuryakin was far from convincing and
Caruana I think he's a better player
than Kuryakin and what do you think
Bobby Idol has to work on to maximize
his chances against Magnus Carlsen well
I mean it was madness you just have to
play well theory so it's talked about
you know improving your middle game or
endgame it's about the strategy on the
match and I'm not I'm not here just you
know to give any advices I just think
it's it's important for Fabia to you
just - I mean to find the right
algorithm because as I said bangles in
the match in classical games go to the
ball no I think van Gogh's is nervous
though again I think I still think he's
a clear favorite but being favorite
sometimes as you know plays it
frequently and he was a heavy favorite
he is Kuryakin and who saw how people
his play was two years ago
so definitely Fabiano has chances so if
he plays as solid and and stubborn as he
did in the candidates we ever seen can
happen so Gary this is Maurice you know
that for American chess this is gonna be
a huge deal we had Bobby Fischer who was
just meteoric we're never gonna see
anything like that again
and of course gata Kamsky had the the
match against Karpov which really did
catch a lot of attention that's what
come on that was not a world champion
well but that said
what do you feel is going to be the
effect of this champion as an American
playing a match do you think you you've
always talked about bringing chess the
United States and getting some interests
but it has not really stuck as much as
we've we're all trying to do what do you
think will be the effect of Fabi being
the Challenger against Magnus first of
all II now I hope that you know it will
it will give us an opportunity to
promote the general improvement on chess
in the United States I mean Fabiana
success is not it's an official success
that was just one one G news you know
that was only the only great player and
with no one behind me even close
then FIFA inspired a new generation but
still it was not it was not as that
Bobby Fischer in in late sixties or
seventies represented home school
popular success is a lot of the great
work generated by by San Luis and and I
think it's it's easy success and his
match against manuals will help us to to
emphasize the importance of this of this
regular work with with young Americans
and also if Bobby does well in the match
so that will be great opportunity to do
chess and so at a new and you new level
in the eyes of American public well
going into this Gary did you think that
Fabiano was the favorite or were there
another player that had your I know I
before the tournament I said that we
it's just we had so many players they
are just very even field and I I think
it's my prediction was that I would
rather say would not win I said it's I
cried imagine dink winning the toilet or
Kramnik because again because age and I
beat doubts about Wesley but then was
other players I thought anything could
have happened but at the end of the day
it's just you know what's happening do
you torment is I mean correct
prove that he's he's very tough and he
has very very good nerves and that's in
he torment with certain mistakes named
because again I said some of the games
that were almost scandalous it's just
you're seeing that's the evaluation
jumping you know from plus 4 to minus 2
and then back to class for in the few
moves yeah I just tell you that the
player Berger knows and then a total
fiasco our audience that that's a clear
demonstration that you could be great
player I think I wrote it probably is
the strongest if you talk about the pure
strengths now and he can show it
throughout the whole year but he proved
the bedrock or in every candidate
rolling since 2010 and it's all about
being being the greatest player it's
about actually playing best chance at
the most important moment and here it's
not surprising that again we we had we
had two two competitors Carolina and I
mean I could ask two years ago and when
you see the two players actually you
know fighting to to for the victory in
the candidates the same forward eight
players double round that tells you that
it's they they they will probably know
best best suited players to win win
discount very good Gary today we got the
announcement that the dates of London
have been announced but not the venue we
hear being mischievous mischievous
persons we're thinking what would happen
if st. Louis were to make a bid would
would that have your support would you
come and join as in st. Louis if the st.
Louis was to successfully make a bid no
I am not doing anything whose feet it's
still a few official match I'll be
watching the match you know happy to
make all my comments but I don't think
that again it's coming it's not giving
advice or what that is just it's a match
still in the hands of an organization
called Hagan
I think it's considering the latest
development with Russian money
laundering operations I think
something that you don't want to touch
and hopefully one day the world champ
nice bye-bye good people buy buy those
terrible chess not about using chess for
a clandestine operations as has been
done for last two decades but now it's
got a moment and let them run the match
in London I'm not sure it would be a
great location that ok they played in
Berlin in wow the conditions I think
they played in New York last match it
was also not the best venue in town but
that's the way they organized the events
and again I don't want to do anything
who's fit in and with the vendor
organized in its current form and shape
apparently if you were advising Fabiano
how much do you think he's going to play
before the match Magnus and Fabiana like
how active should they be before that
November match ok it's it's it's very
hard to give an advice to another player
because it's the III didn't want way too
many games but it was just you know it
was my chest style and the way I I
wanted to prepare for the matches I
don't know what they seemed most
comfortable but he definitely has plenty
of experience
my advice to understand that this is the
match of his life it's it's it's a
chance that you you get probably once
and you should definitely make sure that
by November where the match is played in
London or elsewhere
here will be a knee in his best shape
exactly and for you Gary when you became
Challenger you were going up against
well one of the greatest world champions
ever Anatoly Karpov how much time did
you spend training and preparing was
that a month was it two months I mean
did your life stop is what I'm asking
yeah so you'll remember that when I won
my final candid match
mercilessly slob in April yeah so that
was 994 and whose were different so I
was about to play a match against Karpov
with unlimited number of games and he'll
won one where win six games so it's a
very different demand from matches these
days when you play 12 games exactly and
and though they they cut one must buy
preparation because by original roost
was six months but then camp of Manas
made a decision under pressure from this
Authority this you know just to cut it
five months before at five months and my
tracked by practical engagement was
minimal because after match was business
with Swiss law I played I think I played
only for classical chess she didn't have
other other forms of chess then in in
the USSR against the rest of the world
among them all games against young Timur
and that was it the rest the rest of the
time was spent on preparation and there
were many months so but again it was
1984 we didn't have computers so we just
had to spend time preparing
professionally as as much as we could
looking for new ideas and again not
having the same the same assistance as
you can you can count well we have
something who wants to say hello to you
Gary with Maurice actually is a special
guest we do have Rex Sinquefield in the
building and Rex you have been following
this from the very beginning how do you
feel now watching this game it's not
over yet but it looks like Fabiano
Caruana the young american who now lives
here in st. Louis is gonna win this game
and repeat something that you haven't
seen in quite a long time they haven't
seen it since 1972 and of course nobody
went through candidates the way Bobby
Fischer did but with the three greatest
commentators in the world and with Garry
Kasparov
it doesn't get much better than that I
can't think of anything better and you
know Zack from Tennessee Yasir was
prophetic he said I started looking for
you guys well Zack let me tell
something millions and billions of chess
players throughout the world we're
looking for these guys so you weren't
alone I'm glad you found them if that
happens
jinx it but it does look like he will
win I think he's got a good chance of
winning the tournament and this game
it'll be wonderful
it'll be incredibly great for American
chess now how wonderful the topic came
up Gary mentioned his response to this
how wonderful would it be would you be
willing to make a bid possibly to move
the championship from London to st.
Louis yes absolutely if we have that
opportunity
that's as problematical is real question
whether we'll even have that opportunity
but you know fidei is in disarray all we
have to hope for is more disarray you
know it's like the old great Mayor
Richard Daley of Chicago in 1968 he said
I didn't come here to cause disorder I
came here to preserve this order look I
agree with rice that it is in disarray
that it's yeah but even even even by
dying so they can poison the atmosphere
and I am afraid that action was still in
the hands of Aegon they made all the
arrangements it's being funded by
Russian money as we know from recent
development is funny
very odd origin but before we see some
changes in v-day I can hardly imagine
that we'll see the real real change in
the funding of these events but again
eventually I think it's very important
that then the world champion should
match the whole cycle and more than one
side two three cycles will be run by
professional organization and of course
Rex has tremendous records and if he if
he throws his weight behind the behind
the beat for the future and feeding will
start showing some understanding and
also willingness to change and to depart
from these corrupt practice of the past
however the first one who support the
said Luis as the as the bay location for
for his biggest event in the chess world
Rex that he's he feels challenged by the
fact that I know you can't hear him then
he feels challenged by the fact that
fidei and Aegon in particular is
organizing the event and it would be
problematic although he would throw his
support behind you if you decided to bid
for the event your feelings on that we
get an opening we will take it right now
we don't have an opening see it's right
now the balls in their court legally
they've got possession but if they offer
any way to give us possession we'll take
it well you have pretty definitive words
coming from Rex Sinquefield guys the
games we should we should thank Gary we
really appreciate your presence your
voice your support of chess and of
course Rex you're always been one of the
greatest supporters now the greatest
supporter a chess as far as I'm
concerned simply tremendous work you
guys are doing for us and in support
thank you that's right kudos to you for
being part of making this happen and we
do have breaking news Yasir we do that's
right the game between Kramnik and mommy
Dora was drawn that means that all that
Fabiano has to do to clinch this match
the queen for a spot against Magnus
Carlsen is to draw this better and game
precisely again Gary thank you so much
for joining us and sharing your insights
from you it's continuous celebration so
I think Robbie will probably offer draw
though positions buddy I'm curious to
see if he's offering the draw or he'll
keep trying what's your prediction Arian
what would you do hard to say I he
missed already an easy win he's still
winning it takes time so if he wants to
start celebrating probably the seeking
offer drawn out so let's see what we
should pass so I did say I would I would
bet on driving so you think we can open
the public it's hard for Fabi to play
with energy so unless we should blunder
something doesn't seem he's going to
blonde or something but yeah and
I think fabian and i was thinking about
a letís his next move or his on is
whether he makes a move or an offer
all right well again thank you so much
Terry anyway is in and and now yes it's
time to start thinking about the world
champion wonderful okay guys there's no
guys we have a Gary Kasparov joining us
towards the very end of this game which
is very shortly gonna give Fabiano
Carolina the match against Magnus
Carlsen all he has to do is offer a draw
and that's it yes you can start thinking
about November absolutely this whole
entire goal coming to the tournament was
to become challenger obviously he's
better but he put a lid on it sealed the
deal offer draw would be my approach
absolutely and it's fantastic okay
doesn't have losses it doesn't matter if
he loses the game it's completely
irrelevant he could say let's keep
playing a few more moves let me annoy
this guy prove that you can win the game
now clearly he has no real chances of
winning those griz truth and maybe Fabi
has already offered a draw we don't know
we don't we're not privy to that maybe
he has already offered the drawer and
Grichuk has already said let's make
moves so we will have to find that out
afterwards whether or not that has
indeed occurred because the game is
continuing and district is continuing to
make moves on the board so let's keep
that in mind
Richard could continue rich there is no
difference except a few rating points as
far as music is concerned for taking a
draw right now and and if Bobby
shouldn't lose nerves but we'll see
we'll see it looks like the moves are
continuing though in the game we do have
King D 3 on the board
[Music]
Maurice it's right behind you there and
you're saying that Richard after move
for example like Bishop e5 could decline
the draw well maybe h5 just happened h
h5 so yeah why did he play h5 bishop e4
doesn't threaten age 5 maybe maybe well
he wanted to just go
h4 in Yerevan I mean so if he played
this move and said why wouldn't he say
draw right now that is true
so h5 draw and the guy goes no thank you
make a move you could you're obviously
drawing but we could play for our 50
moves what difference does it make a win
or a loss it's all a draw a draw a loss
doesn't matter so what if he just keeps
playing I mean it's it seems it seems
counterintuitive given that Grisha could
just say well I don't really have any
chances here so why am i continuing to
play but not he knows that it doesn't
matter to him and he could just keep
fighting and just see what happens
intriguing thought I'd assume that pawn
down and the worst ending you would be
gratefully with two hands reach across
the board and accept you with two hands
and your ties but yeah what does a loss
do I mean maybe if you don't well
certainly maybe more than a few dollars
yeah we have to look at the cross table
and besides the money also remembered
that for karate he's got the spot
against Magnus so for him or he's about
to momentarily um so for him the reading
doesn't really matter that much but
there's one goal this year for Grisha
actually you know a few reading points
make the difference right for some prize
money I mean for sure had a very
intrigued very hard-fought tournament I
think he came into the round at the 50%
score right and he's only 12 in the
world right now yeah so every reading
point helps him push right back into
that coveted top 10 spot which is
sometimes important for invitation
absolutely it's all for invitations yeah
and if I could just take a look at our
current standings to see if that would
be impactful on the prize situation
let's just have a quick look so
Alexander Bishop has six and a half
points a draw gets him Clea fair
right and a loss would put him tied with
Kramnik winning would tie him well
that's not gonna happen but if you were
somehow Fabio the blunder terribly you
would tie with bingler in but you're
right the difference between a draw and
a loss is significant because he tie
with his fellow Russian or does he come
in clear how exactly how significant I
didn't see that was the money the money
breakdown was right that big a deal to
come in clear fifth or tie for fifth
I mean clearly commonsensical II he's
done what he had to do he showed that
he's a fighter
he showed that he's willing to duke it
out and he was outplayed by Caruana so
at this time if Kara wanna if Kara wanna
offered a draw after the move age five
then we would anticipate Grichuk should
just say you know what you you proved
yourself I should take the drug but then
we'd have to assume that he did not
offer a drawn there in fact there is the
difference and so the difference is the
difference is either get forty nine
thousand or if my math is right that's
seventy eighty three or get forty-one
thousand five five hundred so it's a
difference of seven thousand five
hundred dollars so a draw is
seventy-five hundred dollars in your
pocket extra
was a change although creature give the
high-stakes poker player do you think
Emmeline but let's could take a look
again at what's at stake for Fabiano
Terre wanna not only is he gonna get
that hundred and seventeen thousand
dollar first prize but a minimum of half
a million at the World Championship
that's the prize for losing if you wins
you get seven hundred plus right and the
endorsements the attention the future
opportunities of the education he's
gonna get from that training process
potentially becoming the world champion
if you can get through Magnus it's a
career it's Esther only yes yes this is
a lifetime achievement whether you win
in November or not lifetime achievement
so many congratulations are really in
order for this young American yes you
know what I love about this event
okay it could have been some winds and
spectacular way to finish and Gary
talked about the mistakes in the event
and from his lofty perch of course he
sees great moves and he he wants to see
great chess and there's no question
about that
but it has been a fighting tournament
and the nerves definitely showed that
was the key word pressure nerves that's
what this is really all about you don't
show your best stuff sometimes when the
pressure is on and we've seen it happen
to the best of them Magnus in his first
quest he also backed in by losing his
last round game so just shows you even
the best of the best can show show
nerves in the critical moments when it's
life changing
this would be life-changing for from
beyond a Caruana but isn't it great that
the last game is this game yeah it's not
one of those situations where this game
is over we're talking about Carolina
winning the event and then we're still
following some other game it just went
right down to what it should be the last
game we're following it and the result
of this seals the deal for the entire
event most appropriate and need
absolutely Maurice and I've been such a
huge fan of avi ever since that Singh
field Cup where he stormed the field and
he was so classy while doing it yeah so
composed so kind to his opponents for
the most part sometimes sometimes he
would show his aggression which makes
him such a great player in the
interviews like I remember once
memorably he said I bet he had a head
out this killer preparation that he had
worked out and then he wanted to play
all the moves quickly vo to just you
know put the pressure on him I wanted to
do that to him they can feel the pain of
knowing I have everything prepared so
always a gentleman once in a while you
can see though that you know who he is
winning in a must-win game in the
penultimate round exactly and by the way
let's add you know we were talking off
air will he pull a Magnus and why us die
that we meant the Sinquefield cup of
2013 where magnus carlsen with a draw
clinched the tournament done deal
just takes a draw and Livan he who he
was playing offered a draw and magnus
looked at the board at the moment down
upon
it's compensation and difficulty of
black converting Magnus with white
pieces said let's play let's keep going
we're wondering maybe grip was the one
who offered a draw in this position
until we know that maybe Fabi said well
I'm not losing so let's keep making
moves so we don't know what the
situation is who offered what until we
know that we won't know what he is
thinking right now except I'm sure if
Robbie's thinking there is no way I'm
losing this position right no way you
have no chances I'm just gonna keep on
making moves I don't need to offer you a
draw in fact bris trick would be the one
who ought to be the one to offer a draw
now and maybe he won't offer a draw
because I say it's rude I don't really
have any chances is up to you so maybe
they just keep on playing and see what
happens I remember that so well that
2013 Cinco cup event not only because it
was at the inaugural year but because
when Magnus declined the draw there was
an electric bolt that went through set
and Maurice I remember you and I looking
at each other said oh my god this guy's
a real thing because you'll remember
that it was basically on the eve of the
World Championship match in Chennai and
it was here in st. Louis that madness
signed the World Championship contract
right he was sending out a bold
statement that I am the Challenger and I
want to play that show it was a lot we
were talking about that after that game
remember the conversation we said this
kid is something special
yes he's Posey you turned down a draw
when the tournament is over and clearly
the joy you clinch there's no extra
prize money involved maybe a few rating
points but you he wasn't even winning
the position not at that month not at
that moment he was down upon and no
chance of losing and you could see LaVon
being nervous and he said you know what
let's make some moves what's the big
deal
and he kept playing when most players
like you said yes both hands would have
gone now thank you very much for the
offer I clinched the tournament that's
it with the money in the pocket he kept
on playing for forever we'll call that
holding a magnus in that situation maybe
Fabi
did that as well or is doing that so let
me play some just to see what happens is
I can't lose this position anything I
can see that sale of it
missing rook g1 that you know we could
have been going home already
killer not been a move to find instead
of rook to be for when he had plenty of
time on the phone reversing the
situation just for a second Maurice
let's imagine because whatever whatever
black was forced to win this position he
had to play for a win is the position
one that's a very good question I mean
he has to break the blockade we talked
about that a long time ago the blockade
on C - we do have King D 3 on the board
by the way King D 3 for white I think I
think we may have had even more moves
that have transpired since then that but
this position here we do have and and
black has played to move h4 in this
position so this pawn is done no palm
breaks on this side and now it's a
question of can you lift this blockade
not very easy to do the rook can no
longer kind of get around maybe a move
like rook to d1 for example has been
played and that would be very tricky to
get around this this move I don't know
yes this Bishop is now ideally placed it
looks like we're now in a stock mode
black is definitely much much better in
terms of extra pawn passed pawn on c3
but winning it's not easy okay
okay fair enough fair enough
whoo I'm just I tell you I had a very
hard time sleeping last night I was
thinking of all of these Thai breaks I
gotten you know like wrapped up about
all of that stuff I thought that you
know fabbi just had to play the position
and if a draw occurred you know except
that but today he displayed a flawless
game I mean really really did he was
never in trouble and he's going okay
140 points for the win I mean in a way
this is even more impressive than the
Magnus because I'm in Fabiano's case
like it's something insane would happen
he were to blunder he gives up a lot
more I mean it seems fuel cup one of the
most prestigious tournaments in the
calendar the most yeah but this would be
giving up the world championship spot
yeah that would be a million-dollar
mistake right that's why I say make a
move I don't care like there should be
five and that's what Gary said we don't
know we don't know we don't know what
has transpired until we knew no until we
asked the players we don't know what
your offers have been made they might we
cannot guess yeah yeah he didn't know
we're hearing from we're hearing from
some experts that in fact he is playing
for the win and then he didn't offer a
draw but will confirm that later but
you're saying you would offer your own
obviously Grisha would nine times out of
ten accept that exactly for the rating
yeah in this from this position yeah I
remember my world junior championship in
1979 what happened as I was going into
the last round with a half point lead
and I needed a draw to clinch the gold
medal and I was playing against
gym-class get and somewhere around move
20th so I offered a draw and Jim who
could get the bronze with victory
declined in a very you know like no kind
of way about ten moves later he had
returned the draw four without having me
to move so I said Jim make your move and
I'll consider it and I had a second John
Donaldson I was running around in the
park because he was so nervous about the
outcome of the game he comes into the
playing hall and immediately the whisper
Ben yes or declined to draw so John came
to the rope and he pulled me over
he put his wrap his hands around my neck
and said yeah sir you didn't decline a
draw did you and I said John even if he
blunders his Queen I'm gonna take it
precisely what happen here this is much
much much more at stake I mean there's
always that you know like bishops don't
move backwards kind of you know some
silly or you know some silly move you're
in this position that Fabio's on the
board
maybe Fabiano wants to play rook this
rook and get this rook over here to the
a2 square right so it would like be
really natural to play move like rook e8
followed by rook a - just forgetting
that oh my god oh my god heart attacks -
remember in the grand Chester I think it
was Vladimir Kramnik who blundered or
ugh there was a backward move by a
bishop which you know like again you
know just take that possibility out draw
thank you very much accolades
what would Magnus do you think Magnus
would go for it should just draw and be
done and we were shocked what he didn't
exactly so I mean yes first of all again
Chris shook maybe have said no three
times or okay all you say this once
maybe Richard already said no and if
that's the case then there just plenty
and there's no more question of a draw
offer of any kind like take a draw the
guy didn't offer you a churro so there's
no draw or if he offered and he said no
then it's done they actually just have
to play and if Chris Turk is saying
let's keep making moves then we talking
about the droids irrelevant we don't
know and it's hard to imagine that a
draw offer has not already been made
right I mean what do you what would you
bet you'd bet that our offer was made by
somebody and I would have suspects you
know suspects by now right right exactly
so what do we have we have we have a
game we have a game and the test is on
Bobby knows if he's not going to get in
the drawer
he's got a couple of hours ahead of him
to try to finish this game off because
the guy's gonna keep saying the guy's
just saying no to your draw for you
gotta go find something this a big crazy
by the way probably somehow loses I
don't know like you just created
insanity on the board if he loses
mommy Jerome is waiting in the wings
exactly he is currently the lead in the
lead tied with Kuryakin but with better
tiebreaks against carjacking so Kai
yakkin is out it is my metier Rob who's
now sitting and saying Chris shook my
buddy
please keep playing just keep playing
you never know what could happen please
just keep moving because if Fabiano
loses suddenly it is one number zero of
whose name is on third right now but
should be in second because he's got the
tiebreak edge on car yakun and and we'll
also have the tiebreaker and we'll have
the topping avianna as well yeah no
Caruana
not as a result of heads ahead not as a
result of more wins but as a result of
soldered burger Oh the third a
tiebreaker
son of Odin burger and wow that's hmm
and here you're seeing manager of
defeats crown the Caruana draws but we
can add now this stat no longer is
relevant mommy zero of draws and Cara
wanna loses and Kuryakin doesn't well
which is already in the books so so that
would be a three-way tie for first and
mommy Dora would win on Mia the tiebreak
yes yeah and we have seen a few
repetitive moves it's not an exact
repetition and again I think it this
last move is an indication that
fabbi is well okay pushing may be strong
but he's not offering the drama
I mean he's sitting there going okay
maybe on a good day I'm gonna put my
Bishop on D to bring my king to F for my
king to g3 and Wow and see if yasser can
find any more help well yeah
it's not about whether or not he's
offered the drawer since that may have
already happened when you say offer a
drawer you you now mean he's not
repeating moves correctly he's not
playing King yes exactly that is another
type of a drawer right a tacit offer of
a drawer correct so he's not doing that
he's actually looking at to make some
measure of progress that we have work a
one Bishop d2 in the position as well
yes so rook a one has been played an
encroaching idea that you were
mentioning happening that King into the
f4 square well exactly that King coming
to g3 would be very nice will always be
able to trade a rook bring our rook down
so that will tie up the bishop and the
king and then king f-14 g3 marching home
that that actually does give a little
bit of counter play doesn't it I mean
the rook is gonna come in through a six
or eight seven and maybe get your e6000
that might be a time where you were five
eight decides like hey do I really want
to calculate all this or just repeat
some moves well it's hard for me to
envision that that the loss of the e6
pawn is actually yeah exactly
I'm gonna come bring my rook down
presumably you're gonna let's just say
keep the blockade right okay matter what
can't get in and then it's sort of like
this bishop is you know keeping that so
rook takes takes and it's almost as if
fun I mean it's almost like I move it
somewhere way back to e4 uh-huh you move
it back to e4 I was about to say I can
check and maybe pick up the Jeep on but
no maybe I put it on that five then
I just put it on there five instead and
that way when you win the Jeep on out
I'll trade ropes I got a four and then
put the King on c2 and was shaking the
father's working he's thinking he's
trying to see if there's a way here to
break through without risk and therefore
get the full point in
when they tournament by a full point yes
what a statement girlfriend yes that
would be a very very big statement
indeed yeah but at this point is just
like you know clinch the deal get the
the scoresheet sign make it official
you know rating points can come in
future events it but that's important
though we talked about this we've seen
this written in books I remember as a
growing player the idea that playing for
our drawers playing for our loss and
this is not the situation right now for
him but it is about maybe making optimal
moves right I mean it's not
he doesn't have to force a draw you said
you get the score see Chinese get the
score sheets shine fine sign say not
three times fast
right I don't think it's about that I
think you could just keep playing
optimal moves
white is completely tied down white it
has no counter play if you objectively
look at the position white has nothing
so black
can make all the faints he wants because
white has nothing right he's too strong
to be thinking about blundering he's got
to be thinking all right if you decline
my draw offer already you already said
no drug it's not my business to say okay
I'm gonna force this draw on you and
make you take it it's my business to
make you beg for it I'm gonna keep
putting good moves on you now the idea
of bringing the king to g3 and as I
start though stretch you're gonna be
like okay okay okay how do I make a
Geron now if you turn if he did indeed
turn it down and we're speculating so I
don't think Bobby has to worry about
anything if I were in this position with
black I mean of course the conditions
being what they are you might say well
no you should be nervous but in these in
this position play like yourself just be
you do you really think you would lose
this position yes if I give this
position to you as black against any
Grandmaster in the world how do you lose
it like a million dollar it's a million
dollar match
yeah
oh you mean it's one in the chances of
you losing yeah I think maybe is one in
a hundred thousand 150 so that there for
you and I feel like you and Gary are
actually doing some intuitive math one
in a hundred thousand when the match is
worth a million dollars I was thinking
less not one in a hundred thousand but
of course when you're dealing with
numbers that big it's hard to do
intuitive assessments because the
numbers are so large you don't have
intuition for them we got 10 fingers and
10 toes also keep in mind that they may
be playing on increments mm okay again
numbers those bit that big it is really
hard to start calculating I can weigh
how do you lose this as white
I mean it's black how do you actually
lose it you don't blunder a piece if you
don't go in there please no how do you
lose it exactly I mean how do you even
envision white figuring out how to win
this position we were mentioning or work
on View to help me with that don't
donate stuff that's yeah so let's say it
might like rook e1 which has a very
nasty idea of bringing the rooks down to
the last rank and if I play a move like
rook a to so you know you could overlook
the fact that that your rook is
underneath oh come on I've got ideas of
OOP excuse me that that arrow was
supposed to be rookie five check okay
King F for King G three very very nice
idea it's hard to see three and not lose
the position you don't give away yes I
know I know
well six pawn who cares Gary felt some
time ago even at the start of this phone
call that the position was actually
winning
so battery yeah the competition itself
thing about chess it's it's games within
games right we have this game but the
larger game is the tournament itself of
luring the points in the tournament
which really which is the one that is
sometimes very intriguing to people
especially for huge cast fans
that's why Jerry joked at us about
loving so which is the bigger game is
over right
okay Maurice do we have more moose one
move that did appear on the board it
seems is the move rook to d8 rook okay
sorry the last minute I had was that
Bishop d2 rook a six and now not the
move rook b1 but instead you're you're
saying look d8 has appeared yes and
actually huh the engines are going
cuckoo for cocoa puffs right now being
saying that this is huge
monumentally huge for black because
somehow blacks gonna be up at least a
piece very shortly before an idea work
takes e4 yeah that's gonna be hard to
continue with the blockade if you move
your Bishop along the diagonal all that
nicely and you you're exactly right and
you can move your bishop along this
diagonal with the idea of trading on c2
and then coming down to the D to square
with the rook
so rook deep oops excuse me not the
moves will be one but rook d8 and
there's still the Kings sliding all the
way into the position via f4 ng or
taking it up if you get the past H pawn
no it's gonna be all she wrote easily
this position is looking juicier and
juicier for black and again losing
chances Fabiano Caruana
I don't think so I think he's relaxed
now I don't we're nervous yeah we over
construct the draw but I always like it
you know there's a very important
concept of exchanging pieces when when
you're up material beginners are told
when you're up trade pieces you're up
upon trade pieces but the better you get
the more you understand you don't have
to just trade pieces to try to win some
end game when you're out material stick
your pieces in your opponent's face
they'll trade for you they'll see your
active pieces and they'll go oh my god
these pieces are too good and they'll
make trades that will help you so you
don't have to force trades just because
you're up bad principal to freeze in
your mind the better principle is keep
playing great moves keep being
aggressive and your opponent will beg
you to trade which only favors you don't
get conservative with the lead and that
applies to trading material that applies
the pressure situations always stay
strong and aggressive and make the
opponent beg to suit your ends in this
situation all Karen has to do is just
keep making score awana type moves if he
keeps playing strong rich Tripp will
have no choice but to try to force a
draw on the board because you'll see the
confidence of his opponent and he'll be
looking around for ways to save himself
or not or are you just gonna go down
that's what I'm starting to feel here
yes that strong message to you know
magnus carlsen none other and I think
Maurice is right though the people that
are suffering the most now are those
that are fans of Fabi but don't really
play a lot of chess
I can you imagine his extremely
supportive parents and friends you know
that are non chess players is my brother
I mean they must be just dying
yeah no seriously I feel it I feel for
them as well but having said that the
position really is so extremely
favorable and what you were saying
you've said it before you have this
great line
you should only trade if they're forced
fantastic force or fantastic
otherwise forced replace right it's
another bad word yes okay so you're
absolutely right so you have to think of
trades as you're going to a marketplace
and you're making an exchange you're
going to trade some good for some other
good and you have to weigh who benefits
from these trades and for example
fabbi at any moment could trade this
rook this white rook and force the
recapture Bishop takes c2 and that's a
trade that's equally good for both
players but it helps white make the
Baltic aid
conversely if black can force y to trade
rooks well it helps black as the pawn
gets one square closer to the promotion
square so black would rather see white
make that trade than the otherwise I
believe absolutely then you play Bishop
c3 and the rook is penetrating the King
still coming in and a lot of work
there's just there's this Fabi just has
to be Fabi when under pressure play like
yourself that is very hard to do when
under pressure play right play like
yourself because you have the result in
mind you're thinking results you're not
thinking chessboard anymore you're
thinking result let's make the result
but if you just keep playing the
position be yourself be confident he's
confident he's optimistic he's just
showing tenacity right now I'll just
keep playing you don't want to take a
draw no problem
I'll show you what happens when you
don't and he's too strong Grichuk in
this position would be the same way any
top grandmaster knows black is not
losing this position so let's just play
and see what happe anna has just made
the move rook on b2 b1 I think he make a
move like that you always want to
absolutely double check because because
of this threat of a discovery you you
absolutely want to make sure that rook
takes d2 does not lose the game and it
does not because the rook on d8 is in
prime position to actually support a
queen okay so that's the first thing and
he just want to make absolutely sure and
you want to do it the other way as well
what about this capture well in this
case even though the bishop does it have
it discovered black has the time to give
a check and now that his rook is no
longer at capture he will he will win an
exchange now argue by the way backing up
even in a case of a blunder rook takes
on c3 yes bishop takes on c3 I haven't
lost the game yeah yeah Bishop takes b1
and I mean you take on you take back
it's terrible to do this now you're
definitely excited to get that girl but
even here it's even there it's a draw
it's only what the level of blunder to
lose is so high that it's a howler it's
got to be miserable what he does yeah he
draw if he makes this drawing forgets
now that said it could happen lightning
strikes out it's a million-dollar match
and it's probably one in a million for
him to lose that so he's kind of risking
like $1 for playing on right right well
but having said all of what we're saying
if this was needed win if fabbi
need needs to win this game he does have
a clear idea
he can play king of four king g3 a
maneuver we were alluding to not with
the idea necessarily of capturing this
pawn on g2 but simply to deliver a
checkmate to White's king with rook e1
check and mate white might well be
sacrificing his rook for the part on c3
and Bishop as well at some point hoping
that that gets him out of trouble
they're given again what I what I was
saying is make the other guy force the
draw if he's not going to take it they
can force it because you're the one
who's in the driver's seat yeah the
problem as I see it Maurice is the long
way to tipperary the white king can
easily be driven away from the g2 pond
and that king is going to just simply
March maybe well in this open easy win
actually in fact Grisha played ping f2
and maybe now Fabi wants to play were k1
with the ideas
Bishop II one check followed by Rafi -
that's a very nice idea that's a very
nice get my work out of the discovery
right I would be also give my parents
less heart attack he's only the anxious
to do that but by the way that we have
the engines are also going up five five
points right now for black saying that
rook d1 is decisive Rick do you want or
do you want and that's been given saying
that it's absolutely decisive now having
the rooks connected a little nasty
threats coming very very fast so Fabi
proving himself right now a win it would
just be the best way to win a point
clear we that's better you would agree
as better than back again with of course
it's so sweet so definitive right like
this against Magnus if he has it if he
wants to have a chance in that match
she's gonna have to win his better
positions and his like plus one end
games because we know how hard Magnus
can fight oh gosh yes so this is
practice right here yeah now that we
just got a quick moment let's just
review how Fabiano is putting the
finishing touches on his fantastic
tournament how did he get here well he
started out fabulously with a win over
Wesley so fellow American and a couple
of trials another victory against ahead
of me are Kramnik with that was an epic
a roller coaster ride yeah yeah one of
the most memorable games of the
candidates another two draws against
Russian players Sergey Karjakin and Alex
Grisha Sergei was swaying terribly at
the time but he later turned out to be
Bobby's main contender a victory over
Levon Aronian and another rollercoaster
ride without game yeah
and then many draws in a row and this is
where Fabi said that with those three
draws in the first half those three wins
in the first half at that time he talked
like maybe he was going in Coast mode a
little bit so much you know you have
that chances and ding Miren
only got a draw there and it was a wake
up call in round 12 he lost the circuit
card a kid and then BAM his form came
back and round 13 and 14 and luckily
this is a 14 round tournament
because the way he's playing in these
last two rounds he's ready to play some
back bass right if the if this had been
around 12 event by the way that loss was
a devastating blow that put him in a
position where he had to win in round 13
any call of duty you responded although
I guess in the end if he had drawn that
game and won this game he would have won
anyway but that's like obviously
speculation exactly exactly and we
catches up on the situation Maurice how
does it look after the move king F whoa
pardon me go ahead use your abort we do
I think if to work a one on the board
for some time now
it's and you mentioned that rook d1 was
but was vos rook d1 looked very bad
although concrete lines it's tricky the
engine sees the positional advantage for
white for being so horrible disadvantage
white advantage for black being just so
tremendous that you you're going to give
black pluses and pluses and pluses but
it's actually not finding a concrete
path to the victory it's just saying
this position is huge and we could tell
King great Bishop great extra pawn rooks
are dynamic but to actually string
together a sequence of moves that wins
the game is still a little bit of a
challenge in this position and he did
play the move rook to a1 and this is not
easy the engines giving rook c4 as a
protecting move to stop the King from
marching in and you see everything on
light squares other than this King which
you can go back to e2 y is is holding
steady and trying to keep the position
and say find something find something
please and if you don't please get
frustrated as we get into time pressure
maybe there you will make some kind of
weird blunder and lose the game then
that would be okay it's a horrible
horrible storyline horrible but that
would be one of the most epic collapses
in history if Fabiana were to somehow
lose this game that would hurt for gain
even speak on it how bad it would be so
the pressure could be mounting inside he
has to be under control just keep us on
it keep his composure
say you've got nothing to do anyway so
at some point he can start repeating
moves alright you can just start well
playing king of six king e5 type moves
and exactly this position that you have
on your board Murray's the thing that
what I would find attractive about the
move rook a one is it absolutely freezes
White's room on c2 the rook on c2 is now
a dead piece it has no moves what at all
how do you attack it how do you well I
would exactly so I would attack it with
the move rook d4 first of all I do like
very much the idea that I want to play
King f4 on a good day but also I have
another idea
if the rooks get traded on d4 I can then
follow up with Bishop e3 check and rook
g1 and gift meet upon on g2 right
because the king is trapped on the beach
now in the upon that say say move like
Bishop h7 just for to show our audience
Shaq and rook g2 and that serious
progress definitely had earlier yeah
yeah so that means you're absolutely
right you can't trade you have to move
your rook somewhere c7 so let's put it
on a white square exactly and now here
what's going on after Bishop e1 check
and I want to get a mating pattern with
Bishop G that's how I could lose careful
okay that is how I could lose yes a
little careful here where are we where
here this this position here however but
no that's alright Maurice Bishop II 1
check King King e3 but sorry you could
put your rook on the other side in this
position according to the engines this
position could be strong and the line
they giving is Bishop 2 8 7 making a
pass yeah and then King f6 this is not
exactly what we want to do is play is
play this line King f6
giving rook no king e to now and Bishop
f4 and try to get some kind of
construction here is there a mate Bishop
Peter Bishop here is mate okay now this
is this is real this you have to be
careful about Bishop here in many areas
is actually mate that was the that was
the mating net yeah that I wanted to set
up good to see you it's pasa it's
possible yeah we see rook T for again
for just a quick SEC then what did you
do you went all the way down
you went look f8 right and this is where
we came up with Bishop II one Shack I'm
still trying to make what are you trying
to do get your Bishop to have four yeah
but King III actually comes with a gain
of temporaries check threat this check
is a right that's a nasty
okay so rook to be four that's another
nice nasty idea to we had mentioned that
if if black doubles on the first rank he
could get a check mating net with rook F
one check and rook e1 check a me on this
is this one is still serious engine and
the engines are not absolutely clear on
this being the best way to play but that
said it does look like he has a great
chance absolutely nice still it's still
look he's still not lost but he's
keeping us in the drama the story line
going and we're still talking about the
game and now we got to worry about the
third time control you can't wait for
that moment where she doesn't call it
and say this is history absolutely
Fabiano will play for the world
championship and we can't say that even
if it's one-in-a-million yeah you can't
say it until it's done and until the
score sheets are signed I know that's so
well from my own experience never let up
just you oh boy okay but rook before and
for Sasha this is
this is no fun either I mean you know
he's doing his best to hang in there but
there's a very concrete threat that rook
is gonna come to be one and then it's
gonna slide over to f1 and it's gonna
start harassing White's King and has
been played and that allows this idea
that even mentioning King to f4 I've
been dreaming about this there for a
while there might even be another
scintillating move here - I notice on
the left part of my screen the moment
you see that little bar that's a chess
engine I don't see its analysis I see
the valuation but after King e2 there
might be some rookie one check followed
by a rookie you want what you guys get
continually looked at kind of doing a
little switcheroo there yes it looks
like so you don't don't step to d3 does
that no that's the that's a nice one
that that's a finish
but King King f2 if I go here I still
have to worry about this the suddenness
of a discovered attack right okay cuz I
was thinking that we would have work f1
Shaq and but here you have Kimi - and my
bishop unfortunately is hanging yeah
what about your idea earlier a Bishop f4
with the idea of Bishop g3 made oh my
gosh take my rook but it's mate oh
that's a beauty that is a beauty
we blundered a rook but we got a
checkmate on the board I love it that's
the way hi there Magnus I love that that
is a pretty finish oh my
so we do have to move rook before can
you two on the board before it was
played you
you're saying roofie for b1 was it was
done a clinical rook check look check
and ishaq king of two and rook b1 this
was a clincher that was lights out
because of that line at the end because
of that meaning that can you know fill
up the construction that's about to
happen to him
Wow okay that was big enough or he's got
a dream he says look I'll put my King on
g3 and I've got rook e1 rook III check
and mate deal with that that looks like
a very very powerful idea by fabbi well
it was stopped by King up to I suppose
the Bonus Time
so nobody's likely to fly on the
increment just yet
by the way this is very nice all the fab
ease pieces are on dark square Bishop
bunny for her maybe waiting in ambush
but we have not blunder / oh yeah
exactly what he's wearing at this moment
a blunder proof vest so do we have King
f2 on the board so I'm expecting fab you
to play Bishop II one check to continue
with his March the king has to go to e2
and King comes to g3
and our very next turn we're setting up
that checkmate on the e3 squared that
we've seen a couple of times this looks
very very straightforward
we saw all King f2 and then rook on b2
b1 from you saw King f2 and then instead
of a bishop e1 psyched work on b2b water
rook on b2 b1 was a fab ease move yep
okay check making the sixtieth move and
pushing the black King away from the g3
square so before what black
the chance to check and bring his king
further into the position check as
forcing the king to drop back I am this
very confident that black is winning 100
but I don't like the sound of the time
pressure introducing itself into the
game I just don't like it's one thing
yeah yeah I just don't like it being a
part of the plot yeah okay that it was
just was just playing with casually
playing forever I'm gonna torture you
forever but now that we have a
sudden-death time control introduce into
the plot it's like her father
we know you're keeping us all you know
on the edges of our seats he might even
be laughing so I'm sure at some point he
laughed at you well maybe I'm not so
sure but it's possible that he's
laughing and thinking you know Rustom is
sweating it out right now
okay whatever long as he doesn't care
about us at all and just plays like
himself but don't screw up the time
situation time does some stupid stuff to
our brains that one is now a monster
that just got introduced in the corner
of the room and is waiting for some some
silliness to go on at the moment still
dominate so completely way anybody's ms2
at least two big wins we've found so far
wings that would just force the guy to
virtually resign they came over that's
ill feeling okay
fabbi has his way about him and what
he's doing really looks impressive to me
Maurice again I'm just looking at very
clean victories abound here I mean there
is let's just make a move for white rook
over row row
there's rook e1 with the threat of
Bishop III check and mate
you gotta sacrifice on c3
and that's an exchange you're not lying
yeah I mean you remember do you remember
was it the rouging Akopian versus
probably on carwash yes from the US
championship last year up to ponds and
winning winning winning and VAR had a
miracle defense that became a win you
know we've seen enough of these stories
yes I got bad memories is floating
around and of course it's okay it's okay
there was some other stuff on the board
and events but how you blundered that
one was right now remembering it that
was so stressful
let's yeah and if we you know what
really want to revisit horror shows from
a sink fill Cup there was this mad time
scramble between fabbi and Magnus and
literally loo 48 I think it was like
rook d2 losing on the spot you know
because of the time trouble that you've
mentioned it does cast a dark shadow
over it happen and this is one of those
you're just winning you're just winning
chess is a cruel game sometimes and we
got a job done we do have a different
move then okay I think we just had this
situation rook check King here the move
that sasha has essayed is Bishop back to
d3 okay so this is the situation on the
board and while maybe one yeah checkmate
eat while the checkmating nets abound
let's just take a quick look at this
this move rook e1 so I'm threatening
Bishop e3 and mate right am i right in
thinking Bishop e2 is boxed and that
must be why he played Bishop d3 right no
I mean no I can't
this is not checkmate anymore
because you have the III swear by the
way look here no no what does he I mean
what can black Barney what can y do what
did he do we do have Bishop d3 oops car
sorry
we do have Bishop d3 on the board I
believe yes yes and then look to be to
look - boy - okay look to be - huh it is
a good looking though because now we can
play we're talking about our trades good
forest fantastic c8 just like trying to
stop right just hanging tough moving -
that's right stop being the bishop well
we come back to our you know sorry I was
a I really want to play Bishop you want
jacket Giga for and you know but Bishop
e1 check will be met by King III but if
you attack the rook again well there's
no choice now I am obliged to give up to
trade right and what is happening here
you have yes look v8 no right to get
behind the pawn and I push pushing
Bishop b4 you have Bishop b1 oh yeah
this should be one keeps me and keeps me
in the game but wait but bishops or
bishops III move your king Bishop see
this is obscene three King III actually
Bishop c3 there's not even a threat
other other than the push here I have I
can I can force you onto the second rank
you're made it if you do oh wait you're
not because I'm cleaning with check oh
yeah this line is lost right so but
Bishop Bishop seat so rook but you have
two bishops
bishops III I have to play Bishop be one
it should be one rookie one I know and
then you have to move your they should
be again very well you you you can
nibble I'll go get the pawn yeah
yep yeah and then I want the H pawn -
you're a member of pawn grabbers and yes
go after the g2 pawn so again not the
g-tube on the h3 pond where you really
care about the hol we're gonna take them
G - what we're gonna take on h3 and we
do that it that is the real goal sorry
we do let me refresh my board over to
you Maurice what is that B's winning
concept here well I mean this move this
move what's this vista board is your
play you play rook c8 here I think I
made a pass like rook c8 yes rook c8 so
rook c8 looks like rook aids a - looks
strong and then we traded and when rook
b8 and rook to b8 and the bishop to c3
and then you know the engines already
panicking with f4 yeah to show that
there's some real challenges here okay -
585 also
be to exceed is giving a trade here and
one no no okay - again we're going to
again so this position is quite critical
and now that it's here c1 could happen -
exactly yeah where are we we're here now
that this position has happened yes risk
has gone into a deep thing and we think
rooks u1 is another minute break c1
Brooke c1 here well you mean after no no
let's say rooks instead of okay - after
CA it's a bad idea this move because
you're getting to play King d4 after a
trade
rooks yeah oddly the engines giving the
move f4 to give the King a place to run
to again which I guess makes sense but
it's it's is definitely huge problems
for black for white right now right
either no matter what he does or
position here after rook to be to this
this shifting of the guard and the rook
leaving and this blockade is certainly
looking very tenuous indeed and it seems
as though Fabi is starting to force
white to play moves that he doesn't that
you need to spend time on that he needs
to spend time on and that's a good thing
if you have to sit here for a while
you need restrict the city or for as
long as possible because then he's going
to get in time pressure this is looking
very promising for black yeah progress
has been made
yeah pieces kind of encroaching on you
know you see them and you're outnumbered
that work on c2 yeah it looks like a
good blockade but the Brooklyn IV it's
not participating and it's gonna get
broken
yes that pond will start to notice you
can run an easy draw I think this this
take this go here you move push you go
here check him he takes the Queen and
okay so you at least have that yeah
right so that's not okay he's not a
you're not getting points on that but he
sees that right that was that's very
easy draw now Fred his true if he wants
it so that's important at least not that
he can draw in there I think you can
always make that happen but big Maurice
can't
fabbi play Bishop II 1 check Bishop d2
if fabby wants to force a draw that
could be a force repetition at once
you mean forcing the King to go back and
forth correct why not we think he's
trying to win don't you
Oh without we would think so we would
think so but I may have news do we have
moves update your board if I'll update
mine and I can only you have another
check and after after Ruby - keenie -
you're right we do have a check
and that is the current situation now
your book see one idea you know what I
like about this I love I love this
geometry oh yeah it's a little exercise
wrapping there rook it's almost like
we're playing some NGO or something you
just surround the rook d7 so everything
kind of darks for I think rook c1 really
looks good yeah rook c1 would force this
capture and suddenly the pawn is there
and then your bishops coming here that's
big that's a big deal
progress and closer now it looks to
winning the Jeep on yeah now Bishop here
Bishop here and give me a pawn that's
right mm okay now we don't I don't feel
any danger for black even in the time
situation I feel no once a pair of
Brooks came off the board yeah there's
no losing chances zero not a chance
anyway he was back it was no way would
lose anyway it seemed but here the odds
are even more minimal that you could
possibly win we're adding some zeros
guys and you'd like to say zero zero
zero and we're adding zeros and
obviously if another pair of bursts come
off then there's absolutely no way to
lose oh so it's getting so that draws
clinched can he win this position
however will be the main question looks
like rook b8 is absolutely forced to
stop this pawn from advancing and then
you just defend the guy and now we've
got a nasty little threat called Bishop
d4 and rook g1 and more progress on the
way that's right another pawn falling
and they probably ought to play that
move you looked at earlier F for track
just to stop that but then another pawn
is following exactly and that's 2 pi and
these bishops of opposite color middle
games are always favored the player with
the initial save quite a number in fact
fewer with the rooks on and there are
ways to encroach on your opponent's king
even with the tips of opposite collar
precisely it's specially excuse me
especially with bishops as obviously
call this way if you cannot fight my
bishop as long as I have major
pieces on the board that's right you are
in trouble because you can't fight
whoever has the initiative owns the game
and that's what's happening here it's
especially you have a pronounced
advantage of virtually up a piece what
is the white Bishop doing defending it's
it's an irrelevant piece yeah it's not
doing anything it's just sitting there
it is
it is garbage and we don't have that F
forecheck idea anymore after like in
those lines with Bishop T 4 and what do
you want because we can just take the
bishop yes oh yeah that's just gonna
lose that crucial pawn on g2 and and win
the game yeah absolutely and we have
breaking news the game is over
Fabiano Carolina has won against style
[Music]
falling this is where Fabiano lives and
university parties who are in the
Central West End as he has earned the
first-place prize of over a hundred K
but we've mentioned it before this is
really worth a million dollars plus yeah
they're life-changing a career changing
experience as he will be challenger to
magnus carlsen a billion dollar price
match full point when after he won that
seat filled cup in sizzling fashion
growing 7 and o to start the tournament
there was nothing in his life he could
do to do better there was only one thing
which mattered was now his sights on
Magnus Carlsen
it took him from 2014 to 2018
to be able to realize that potential
that everybody was talking about but he
has finally done it and come November he
will challenge Magnus Carlsen for the
world title and there are cheers going
on in the job there cheers everywhere
around the world for a fan of Fabiano
Caruana and for chess guys let's admit
it this is a match everybody has wanted
to see and even if Magnus as gary has
said is the favorite having the
experience and is the best way in the
world this is still going to be a
fascinating match absolutely
Bobby will have his chances for sure
what a fabulous finish you want to just
replay those final moves because rook c1
was the choice visual absolutely rook
takes B to C B to rugby a bishop to c3
and after a quick pitch up to e4 Bishop
to d4 King e2 and I believe a few more
moves were played it looks like King f4
was played on the board rook to b7 King
G no looks like there's another Brook
move let me for let me refresh it was
here right
he played rook King F for route B 4 and
then e 5 making closing the picture
everything on dark square is making this
bishop in effect upon it is now
officially just upon that's guard that's
able to guard b1 but that's it and then
he played rook to b7 King into g3 this
is dropping h3 dropping pawns will push
simple technical and this rook is frozen
this Bishop is frozen blacks just up
material now as he's going to Queen his
H pawn clearly needing to resign this
final position nice effort by Fabiano
didn't read all the wins he had a few
wins he could have knocked them out with
but now it just doesn't matter a full
point win clearly the rightful
Challenger to Magnus cross no doubt
after that victory no let's take a look
at some of the candidate tournaments
well we're gonna take a look at the
final standings Levon Aronian came in as
such a favorite having a phenomenal 2017
but he finished in eighth place 20 pay
for his efforts and in 7th place we have
our own American star Wensley Sol but
this was not his tournament he takes
home 27k next up we have a tie for fifth
Alexander grisha taken home 41k he lost
his final game and that put him in the
same spot as the formidable Vladimir
Kramnik also tied for fifth who
seriously entertained us throughout this
tournament ah sir yes sir what so he put
an nope
about it he stole the show his games
were just amazing and full of contact
you know I all we had the Chinese
Challenger ding Loran he fabulous it was
still in contention up to the last round
he everything swung his way he could
have become the Challenger to
magnascribe close so workplace doesn't
look good but it was a lot stronger than
it look meanwhile tied for second place
this guy really kept 5 piano looking
over his shoulder all event
mommy Nara what a fantastic tournament
he had AZ and he would have been a tough
Challenger as well well it was that
round 12 that tripped up both of these
gentlemen none I was actually Sergei who
tripped up Fabio self in pole position
that's right but Sergey Karjakin just
incredible starting the permits so badly
and then bringing the heat and defeating
at Fabiano in a must-win situation that
blasted the candidates a wide open
exactly but here it is the winner
fireworks all over the Central West End
is Fabiano Cara wanna becomes the US
challenger to Magnus Carlsen and that
match is set for a London in November we
can't wait to watch that yeah this is a
million-dollar win for Fabiano Cameron
if he wins over 100k for first place
plus a minimum 500k in this championship
plus the the endorsements the seed and
connects candidates its average is
everything and hopefully this will
really create a kind of a renaissance
for chess here in the United States but
let me interrupt myself and say we have
a very special guest some very happy
people that's right we mentioned them in
the child yes we didn't realize they
were here watching well they are locals
that's right Santina and Luca Rana the
proud parents of the Challenger are with
Maryse absolutely first of all
congratulations mom and dad you're
everybody's mom and dad
tell us since you know how does it feel
to watch your youngster pull this off
and is now the Challenger to the world
title like a dream and maybe I wake up
but I'm very excited I'm very excited
for Fabiano either services the United
States the services of some toys in the
services I think that if I can't believe
it my life is pounding like the rest of
us Lou you had to make a big decision at
some point taking Fabiano out of
Brooklyn in Park Slope where I lived we
were Co Co residents for a while to take
him to Italy take him to Europe so he
could play and grow in an environment
where there was a lot of chess do you
feel vindicated now that you did that I
do it was a gamble and there was a
bigger gamble
then we actually realized what it was at
the time of embarking on the journey but
it seems to have paid off indeed it does
and tell us this did you how did you
feel when he was in Moscow and he lost
that last round and I took her out to
karaoke in the first time what was that
like to now go through this two years of
him coming back on this quest well as I
said mother and I am NOT a good chess
player
I always anticipated worst
so I had to step back actually and not
to follow the tournament I told I asked
my husband to support me about not to
follow the tournament just because other
one like influence with my emotions
about out picturing the same result of
three years ago so I said to myself it's
going to be a beautiful surprise so it
could be an okay life continuous yeah so
we at the loo say okay so we don't
follow the tournament until joy called
us today
Wow what did that feel like when you
heard our say yesterday Lou
it's also dr. the game of uh solver
yesterday the tournament was all a made
a mistake and so he yesterday and I for
some reason on the calendar I thought it
was the last round of a player who is no
player every so it doesn't annoy you one
and definitely said no there's another
game tomorrow we try to stay off the
roller coaster it is a roller coaster
when you're on the roller coaster you
really can't do much else other than you
know and so it is you I lose like three
weeks of my time following the
tournament so I do other things that are
productive or I know I can't help what
he's playing tell me that because we do
have very involved parents in the chess
world famously Magnus Carlson's dad has
been a part of his career pretty much
from the beginning have you when did you
decide to step back into Carolina's
control his own chess career well he
decided that he pretty much want that
kept on pushing for more and more
independence and he got to the point
where he said you know I really want to
start making some of my own decisions so
of course we consult on everything but
you know he's in the lead basically in
terms of decisions and now he's won how
are you going to ignore this upcoming
match you know yeah we do we do a lot of
work before the before the competitions
involvement before the competitions but
once the competition starts of course he
falling at the wood making the Moose
can't do anything else
so in terms of chest training chest
camps physical training where you know
that's what we do we prepare all that
my husband is keeping managing me it's
got here and of course I am the one
consulting you know and keeping
everything like you know smooth but we
are the one preparing for the chess
games and like you know you know and
what it's going to go now is something
so we had one set of problems similar
problems but they're somewhat different
now absolutely we'd be working on this
other set of problems between now and
November I'll give you guys the last
word on this
what are you feeling just right now how
how sweet is this I don't get too
emotional about these things right I
don't
really right now yeah I mean I'm looking
I'm looking towards November right now
that's what my mind just right now I
feel that far beyond oh we did a service
set and um he's if Stalin is
extraordinary and you know it's like
well it was not so easy going to Europe
and limits country at returning to his
country there's a lots of personal
growth and I think that he really
deserved it and and it brought its best
because you know when this when it's
very stubborn it that is his best and
nothing in this tournament he really was
saying you know this is a ton of me
nobody's got to take away from me so
then only price is best point yeah I'm
very very proud you mentioned this idea
is just add you mentioned this idea that
he left his country a lot of player a
lot of people have have said well you
know he's really Italian he's really
European he's not really American
somehow it seems silly given that he was
born here and educated here
one American right I hope in war in all
aspects how does that how do you feel
about that him doing it as an American
coming back home and getting it done
this is where he belongs
so he's returned going to Europe was one
thing changing the federation's was
another strategic decision I think it
was a good decision at that time coming
home was the main goal well we always
felt that he would return here you know
I think that also we you know this is
not Fabiano's success we have to see us
at the SAS United States you know we
have to bring down the victory to the
country and the the fight or to the
country which I think that we have a
good chance right yeah yeah absolutely
well congratulations we know this has
been a long journey and you are being
behind him all the way and we get to see
you guys and congratulate you very proud
parents indeed
Fabiana Khurana and his parents thank
you they have done it and he is now the
Challenger to magnus carlsen for the
title of world champion Thank You
Maurice and our our congratulations as
well Jennifer has been a thrill what
today in Cheshire we've had and what a
tournament showed you that there's like
this we talked about game within a game
but then there's a bigger game of the
preparation the career and a lot of not
just the brain and the talent but the
people around you exactly your parents
the supporters
well that emotional support is so vital
to a chess player as well just to know
that you know you're going to a
tournament and all the people who are
important in your life are backing you
completely that's just a very powerful
impetus for absolutely I mean all he's
doing it for the coaches that he's been
working with fans
and you know it's just I know that the
sing fields are so proud of Fabiano for
you know the fact that he's a st. Louis
right now and you know I you know
obviously some of his preparation will
happen right here in this town and click
the brain the brains that you have in
st. Louis because of this chest blow in
the air it takes it to the very top
absolutely and Fabiano will go from this
tournament to Yankee that then he
returns for the US Championship right so
if you want to come and personally and
congratulate Viviano on his fantastic
historic victory personally you can do
it by visiting the st. Louis and the
u.s. championship in two weeks time oh
yeah if you were thinking of visiting
st. Louis this is your chance April 17th
the 30th come on down for a weekend see
the World Championship challenger in
person and additionally you know he's
got he's got some competition yes
look who's gonna be here when we sell
the home our top three players in the
world
Alexander only shook many time us
champion two players from the gold medal
winning Olympiad to Ray Robson Sam
Shanklin our very own version of Kobe
and many time competitor in the US
Championships here he archbishops
that's what I wanted to say one of the
leaders of the Archbishop Pro chess team
Jeffrey Jones your player finally
getting back on track now back in the
world top 100
want to tournament the classic that's
right he's great laughs it's all these
guys are gonna be hunting for Fabiano
but you got to ask yourself yes papi I
don't got nine out of 14 amongst you
know the best players in the world cram
McPartlin hundred crowd doing this crowd
or kind of relax it's gonna be so
dramatic just to find out exactly ladies
by the way very always classy Nazi
because he is already sent out a tweet
congratulating Fabiano on his fantastic
victory and cleaning out how great it's
going to be for Chaz absolutely and we
have the returning champion Sabina
Pfizer returning to defend her
championship title the veterans arena on
a path eV and of course Jennifer U is
now in the top path and she's really
been on fire as a couple international
master norms no another player who of
course was closely watching was
Tocqueville raha me and who often does
the Twitter the social media and the
newsletter for big events like the sink
the old cups he says that it was
sometimes she couldn't watch today
I know but final thoughts on this
historic day for American chess from
Maurice Ashley guys we have been
together for a long time and we have
seen some amazing moments and what a
beautiful career to have to be able to
watch chess history in the making this
has not been seen first of all Bobby
Fischer 1972 we did see gotta calm ski
which some have said may be a 96 doesn't
count as strongly but it was definitely
a big accomplishment but that was over
two decades ago and to see an American
challenger to be able to be an
eyewitness to it happening to be alive
when it happens it's just simply
magnificent Fabiano Caruana realizing
his sound all that work he did leaving
home
leaving American soil going to Europe
getting all that seasoning and then
finally coming back like his parents
said they always wanted to do it back
home it's a moving moment it's a
touching moment and it's also an
exciting moment for American chess and
for world chess because I think
everybody knew that this young man
really was a rightful Challenger ever
since he came and blew up the whole
building by winning that Sinquefield Cup
back in 2014 he is here now it has
arrived and I can't wait for November to
see that epic match I can't wait either
and you're right Maurice we've been
waiting ever since that's that
incredible Singh field Cup result and
even Magnus at that point said yeah
looks like he's the guy yeah five years
later he is the guy and that's official
indeed and I agree with Maurice though
that of all the historic things we've
seen you know the Sinquefield Cop the
the Magnus Carlsen victory all the
different US Championships no Sabinas
incredible win last year and nause the
year prior this is very emotive yeah
Kasparov returned the Kasbah return
exactly but this could just take the
cake yeah you know this could change
American chess we all love this game the
for everybody involved in chess the US
Chess Federation all of the chess in the
school's programs and all the things
that the taint Lewis Chess Club are
doing to try to promote the game and
give resources to people who love it
it's all it's all just going to explode
what the infrastructure that people have
put into place is now going to be used
of course and by the way our show we
have a lot of supporters behind the
scenes let's have a look at our staff oh
yes here they are our wonderful cast and
crew we've got pom we've got Jen our
director who fills in for Randi
Sinquefield who was the founder of the
spectrum studios
Marcus and you see market Tammy he came
back there Brian yeah big Tom the
director who's keeping everything going
exactly
doesn't matter how exciting it is and
for this tournament always been really
exciting there is always a Marik's
sighting and of course Erik Rosa who
makes all those beautiful graphics and
those montages the teasers to open up
the show they're really really yes he's
good he's a really good keeps getting
better
yes and you know the other thing about
this crew is you heard a lot of them
cheering of course they would cheer for
probably any American challenge or
they're all great guys but Fabiano is
really a gentleman you know he likes to
socialize when you know he's not
involved in a serious competition and
you know he's a fan favorite yeah no
question we play a lot of bughouse
against one another too is that part of
the secret training yeah really really
deserving what can I say just a you know
salute fantastic
and so next up is for us the US
Championship so just amazing to be able
to hear from Fabiano himself at that
tournament I'm sure somehow Maurice
might touch on this result in the
postgame interviews yeah well give us
your final word Larry so how do you feel
I mean just story go find a club and go
do some dancing baby this was absolutely
just such a great result and to finally
see it happen it's just amazing it's
just absolutely amazing and yeah I'm
gonna be asking him a lot of questions
about that but I can't wait to just
actually see him punch him a little bit
then give him a big hug he got it done
the young man has arrived he is now boss
and it is time for him to prove himself
at the world championship level so it
just doesn't get any better than this
it's it's here guys you got to pinch
yourself because it's here and what is
mean one Rex Sinquefield who has said I
want an opening so that I can maybe
bring the World Championship the st.
Louis whoa whoa what right here in
American soil
to see that that's his and look the
possibilities they've just begun and
we're gonna be talking about it for the
next seven months it's just absolutely
incredible that's right for the next
seven months in the United States eyes
are gonna be on Ches eyes are going to
be on this young man who is going to be
the Challenger for Magnus Carlsen and
the next stop is going to be right here
in st. Louis on April 17th where the US
Championship and the US women's begin so
thank you everyone for staying with us
on this historic tournament and signing
off for everyone here at the st. Louis
chess club and for Yasir Sara Juan and
Maurice Ashley Thank You Jennifer
good night everyone
[Music]